e
okay members please take your seats
started good morning environment
agriculture committee please members
started
uh okay representative Bixby would you
allegiance aliance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all thank you and good morning
everyone
I want to uh
welcome uh three substitutes to our
committee this morning representative
Harry Bean sitting in for Matt kulan
representative
kulan representative Deb Sim D Simone
sitting in from for uh representative
verville and representative Doug Thomas
sitting in for Jake brard representative
brard I want to thank you very much for
um for coming and joining us and and um
volunteering your
time this morning we are going to uh be
executing some
bills
and me get my papers together and get
all together here all right so our first
Bill I'm going to open up the exec
session for HB
1316 relative to the co-ownership of
dogs and I would like to uh make the
motion
itl do I hear a
second Megan Murray representative
Murray good morning
um and I will speak to the motion of itl
for this bill um we heard testimony
about um the co-ownership of dogs and
how that relates to
contracts and I I understand
that the reason why this bill was
brought forward was because of an issue
in a town
where some folks were setting up a uh a
Doggy
Daycare which um they were then under
the premise of saying that they would be
they they have co-ownership of dogs or
that they would be um watching somebody
else's animals and I the whole thing in
order to change Statute in order to um
prevent some kind of fraudulent activity
like that it sort of didn't make any
kind of um legislative sense as to you
know this is seemed to be more of an
issue of local enforcement of their
zoning
regulations and so um the thought is
that this is not an
appropriate uh Bill to to to accomplish
that um any other discussion on this
particular
bill so I see none and um I would
request that the um clerk call the rooll
thank you madam chair the motion is itl
on HB 1316 representative kraton I
representative ktoa yes representative D
Simone yes representative Davis
represent Thomas yes represent Bean yes
Penza yes represent smart represent
Bixby yes represent
sopus yes represent dutsi yes represent
Murray yes represent Jama yes represent
H Haskins I represent Howard represent
NAB yes represent moris yes represent
ban oh she's not here um madam Madam
chair
yes 190 shall we put it on
I I'm sorry what was the account that 19
okay all right I'm going to close out
the exact on HB
1316 and open up um the exec for HB
1173 do I hear a motion Madam chair I'd
like to make a motion to itl HB
okay may I speak to um yes please speak
to your motion thank you madam chair
um we already have laws on the books
dealing with this issue um and we felt
uh that that that the laws that we have
on the books are sufficient at this
time okay there any other oh I have it
here any other discussion representative
Bixby
yeah I I think that um one of the we we
did get uh a letter from the um
constituent who the uh who who the
sponsor had U Been discussing this with
about uh sort of discussing a little bit
more in depth some of the issues around
why it wasn't working and having looked
at the looked at that letter and looked
at the
um looked at the
statute uh there there were there a
couple of points in the letter one was
that the um that the fines were not
really the fines were outdated and were
not uh enough to actually function as a
deterrent that may in fact be the case
however when we're talking about uh
criminal fines uh that's something that
needs to be uh reviewed by I I either
it's either criminal justice or J
Judiciary I I'm I'm blanking on which
one it is but it needs to be reviewed by
a second committee and we don't have
time to do that review at this point so
if there's a question of increasing the
fines that's something that should
happen with the bill bill we bring
forward next year uh in terms of the uh
the statute being s unclear I did not
see the statute as being unclear it
seemed very clear that uh there was a
there were different
grades of offenses that um uncontrolled
dogs could commit and that uh those
could there were different ways of
handling those
including uh bringing the case before a
circuit court judge who would then
assess the situation with all of the
relevant context and I think that uh
putting into law doing anything that
with this that would uh in in any way
get rid of the
human discretion the the discretion of a
trained judge in this case would be
inappropriate because there are so many
variables that we talked about in our in
our um work session so I think that this
this really needs to be itl we may
revisit the issue of um of the fines
next year but I think that that's not
not something for this
term any other discussion represent
Duty thank you m Madam chair um I agree
that maybe this isn't the bill um that
uh needs to be passed but um we have
seen we have animal cruelty laws on the
books we have vicious dog laws on the
books and we have seen this over and
over and over again in this committee
that these laws are not enforced or
there's a slap on the wrist okay I mean
I can just tell you three points in my
life one we had a dog owner in my
neighborhood who refused to leash the
dog and it would charge people that were
running around the you know runners in
the neighborhood uh I have an
acquaintance whose daughter young
daughter was disfigured by uh a vicious
dog who bit her ear off and I worked for
a gentleman who had two of the breeds
that were mentioned in this letter um he
had uh his staff over for a meeting
and those dogs were locked in another
room and for two hours they were clawing
at the door and barking and I mean I'll
tell you I mean there were like 15
adults in the room and all of us were
frightened of those dogs so this
committee needs to make some
recommendation to maybe having a
commission or whatever to understand why
the laws that are on the books are not
being totally
enforced representative
um sorry representative ktoa thank you
madam
chair um I do somewhat agree with
representative
duty but I think there's a disconnect
and the disconnect is is in the
education of law enforcement in the
judicial system and that is currently
being worked on uh to educate them
better to possibly have training classes
at the police academy so that they can
understand
uh the the animal cruelty law so that
they can be enforced better so um that
is that is really where the disconnect
is and I do believe that there are
efforts underway to improve
discussion okay seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role thank you madam
chair representative kraton hi
representative kto yes representative D
Simone yes yes represent Davis yes
represent Thomas yes represent Bean yes
represent Kenny yes represent
Penza yes represent smart represent
Bixby yes represent
sakas um yes represent Duty yes
represent Murray yes represent Jama yes
represent H Haskins I represent Howard
yes represent NAB yes represent moris
yes represent ban yes Madam chair yes 20
shall It Go on
consent sure seeing no uh
objection okay I'm going to close out
the exec on HB
1173 and open up the exec on HB
151 which
is
um yeah the uh
yeah just get the name here okay yeah
repeal in the requirement to register
register dogs
annually um do I hear a motion for that
representative Murray I'd like to make a
motion if I may sure I'd like to make
the motion of itl please okay uh do I
hear a second a second representative
Katon seconds would you like to speak to
your motion representative Murray uh
thank you madam chair yes I think we
have looked at this um be um this issue
currently and um we had a very lengthy
discussion about the potential of
removing this um and um Not only would
it create problems for local
municipalities but it would also then
put community at risk to not have uh an
annual registration we also talked about
the potentiality which we have looked at
in previous years of biannual
registration or excuse me every other
year registration um and that would be a
very difficult thing for Town clerks as
they had mentioned to um be able to test
you know to look through and see who was
up for that registration at which time
the annual um dog uh registration of $7
right now also that money goes to local
programs as well for other things
outside of um that that go um towards
animal welfare and um Healthy
Communities for um those who are in the
pet community so I that's why I think
that we should just leave it the way it
is any other comments on this
I mean I would I would just want to
comment about um how important it is for
people to um to register their dogs
annually it's not a whole lot of money
$7 and if you're a senior citizen I
think it's
two um and and the fact that
registration is coupled with the uh
rabies vaccination that's the most
important thing is to make sure that our
dogs are
um are vaccinated um to protect not only
them but also uh the human population
and so
um the the the law the way it works now
um works well and um I I don't see any
any reason to um to make any changes to
it or repeal it obviously so I will
support the itl any other
comments see being none I would request
the uh clerk to call the role
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair the motion is itl h501 represent
Katon I represent coma yes represent D
Simone yes represent Davis yes represent
Thomas yes represent Bean yes represent
Kenny yes represent Penza yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent
sopus yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray
yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard represent NAB
yes represent Morris yes represent ban
yes Madam chair yes 20 shall It Go on
consent sure any
objection thank
you I'm going to close out the exec for
HB
151 and open up the exec for HB 1556
relative to exempt from the rabies
vaccine do I hear a motion
representative sofikitis um I would make
a motion to move um 1556 FN as
itl and do I hear a second I'll second
that representative Kenny seconds would
you like to speak to your motion
represent sopus yes um over the years I
think the last time we heard a bill for
this was around six years ago um
about the exemptions for the rabies
vaccine this program of vaccinating all
dogs the part that I have that's um that
I still had six years ago is that all
animals receed the same dosage um and so
there's a lot of research but the
research is not complete yet so this
program works remarkably well we don't
have any problems and so it should stay
the the way it
is any other questions or comments
regarding this I I do want to um make a
comment regarding and I did share the
the letter that I had sent to Dr
craford asking him um you know is there
a
way uh and should we or could we lift
the protocols for say dogs that are
older that are ill that are sick that
maybe the owners have trouble getting
muzzles on them putting when they're
when they have to go
outside
um and you know I'm sensitive to the
issue that uh representative ammon's
constituent had brought to us you know
about her her old sick
animal and uh having to deal with uh
some of the rabies protocols and his
response was that local rabies control
authorities already have the latitude to
establish local standards and in
addition when the animal is
outdoors it shall be muzzled in a manner
approved by local rabies control
Authority so you know I think there
there is some latitude in the law that I
guess if the if the constituent would
talk to um you know the local animal
control person
that there may be you know a remedy for
her um but in general um he we're
hesitant to make any kind of changes for
protocol especially for dogs that would
be put outside in their backyard that's
fence because we know animals can get
loose they can jump the fence they can
find a way out and that might um pose a
high risk or you know at least another
risk for um exposure to rap
or not only for the animal but you know
the animal could get in contact with a
rapid raccoon or
something so I think that um you know
any any any of these bills that come
before us seeking um exemptions or
changes in the protocol um we have to be
very sensitive and and um you know look
at what what different
ramifications could occur because it
representative
Bixby yeah so uh one um point that is
sometimes brought up by people who think
that uh rabies control restrictions
should be
reduced is that there is rabies already
in the endemic in the the wildlife of
the state and that we haven't had a
problem with it uh the reason we haven't
had a problem with it is because we do
have a strict ra rabies vaccination uh
program and uh it is you know bats can
carry it a bat can get into your house
and expose your dog without your knowing
it uh dogs are curious they could get
into you know if there's a dead raccoon
because it's died of rapies and they
sort of start nuzzling that they can be
get get exposed there are many channels
of potential channels of exposure where
the owner would not not know that the
that the animal that their dog their pet
was getting exposed and we need to have
a strict as possible a rabies
vaccination program and if there are
exemptions granted for specific reasons
those dogs need to be overseen
particularly
closely any other comments represent
Penza i' just like to Second a little
bit of what you said um um chairwoman
talking with someone that um had
concerns about this bill just because of
the same thing an older dog and all of
that I think that the we always want to
Champion local control and I think that
many of these folks that work in um
whether the department in animal control
they totally have a heart and if that
dog doesn't have the you know skill set
anymore to be jumping fences and all
that kind of stuff I think that uh I
think this that can totally be handled
on a local level where you know
exeptions can be made because you know
that dog is uh you know is doesn't have
the verocity anymore to be able to do
those things so I appreciate what you
said but I I think that we need to keep
this in place as well and I think this
can be handled just based upon a
community and having a heart for those
situations
specifically thank you any other uh
questions or comments having to do with
this bill
okay anyone
else okay I and now request the uh clerk
representative Kat to call the role
thank you madam chair the motion is itl
and hb1 1556 represent kraton I
represent ktoa yes represent D Simone
yes represent Davis yes represent Thomas
yes represent Bean yes represent Kenny
represent Penza yes represent smart
represent Bixby yes represent sopus yes
represent Duty yes represent Murray yes
represent Jam yes represent hkin I
represent Howard represent NAB yes
represent
Morse yes represent ban yes Madam chair
yes 20 shall It Go on
consent
sure thank you seeing no um objection
I'm going to close out HB
1556 and I will now open up the exec
session for HB
1102 relative to the definition of
animal cruel crty do I hear a
motion represent Bixby I move
itl um I will second that and
representative Bixby would you please
speak to your motion so um we heard a
lot of testimony a lot of evidence and
uh what that what that testimony uh
seemed to indicate was there is a
problem and uh that the problem that um
that is a it's a problem where um if
breeders are not careful about what they
you know their their procedures they can
end up breeding dogs that are
congenitally going to suffer and uh the
but um the question becomes how do we
deal with that and uh is there a
solution that the New Hampshire
legislature can come up with with that
will deal with that effectively uh the
the solution in the original bill would
have created a new part of the criminal
code that would have
criminalized uh
breeding uh animals and that had some
sort of a painful deformity uh and uh
were selling them and uh there are two
there were two problems with that one is
that putting it into the criminal code
where it was
uh the other is uh what the mechanism of
enforcement would be uh we had testimony
uh from someone who has done animal
cruelty uh
investigations uh which are fairly
complicated Affairs she described the
processes that would be necessary and uh
when she was asked if it would be
possible to successfully do an
investigation and
prosecute
uh this as it was laid out in the
original bill it would not be possible
um the uh so uh the other issue with it
with that with the original bill was the
uh lack of clarity in the definition of
what the problem was and so the original
bill was not
um just did not have what it took to be
good legislation or to become good law
uh there has I have seen a um an
amendment proposed and the amendment
gets rid of some of the worst problems
of the original Bill uh it does not make
it a criminal act it makes it a
violation but in terms of the how that
would get uh enforced it's even it's
it's even harder to see how that would
be enforced and in terms of the
definition of the problem it would
basically just criminalize three breeds
and I don't think we should be
criminalizing breeds of dogs uh I don't
think that this is a problem that can be
uh handled by a single state there may
be some way of uh in the future of
requiring that dogs with genetic markers
uh are uh dogs that that might be prone
to this are tested for genetic markers
and those dogs with those genetic
markers might be somehow prevented from
being bred uh doing that on a state
level would
be pretty much impossible so uh I don't
think that there is something for us to
study here uh so I I think that uh this
itl any other discussion representative
Duty uh thank you madam chair I agree
with most of what representative Bixby
has said uh except for the last part
uh regarding um studying the issue
further uh I think we have uh a good
amendment that has come forward that has
drastically reduced the scope of the
original bill um and I think this is
definitely something that we should need
to study further es especially if we
have breeders who
consistently uh push the boundaries uh
in order to um have animals um that can
uh better compete uh in um uh some of
the dog shows um that are around the
country and I think in our state so um I
will not be supporting itl uh I would
like to see a motion of interim study um
so that we can reduce those breeders uh
who may have more of a financial
incentive to breed these dogs that
suffer um rather than the compassion
that we know most of the Breeders have
for the breeds that they breed thank you
representative H Haskins thank you madam
chair I'm going to agree with
representative Duty I I think the
testimony was just too compelling to me
to itl this bill I think there are
things that we could do to advance those
arguments further and I agree with
representative Bixby that it it may need
Federal action but we can't
affect that at the moment but what we
can affect is what we do here in New
Hampshire so I will vote against the itl
in favor of intern study representative
Murray thank you madam chair um I one of
the I I thought that the bill
highlighted a lot of very important
considerations I learned a lot like you
had mentioned um one of the things that
I do think was compelling for me to hear
in support of the itl was um testimony
around the AMA VMA the American
Veterinary Medical Association um and
creating na a national position on um
direction to um potentially breeders
breed clubs organizations on the
direction that they felt needed to go
for a multitude of of congenital or or
bred for conditions um that were either
um desired traits or otherwise and I
think that um to what representative
Bixby spoke to uh we heard hours and
hours and hours worth of testimony and
um I would like to see there being a
more
um a a larger National sort of response
to this because this isn't just one area
we see um animals coming from all across
the country in some circumstances this
is just not also just a New Hampshire
breed
issue
thank you um representative ger and then
representative kraton thank you madam
chair so I I was
definitely inclined to support itl uh
until having looked at the proposed
amendment I think offers some good uh
tightening of the original Bill uh and
addresses some of the concerns that I
really had and I am in the end you're
really concerned from some of the
testimony we heard we're talking about
the four most popular breeds of dog dogs
here and where there is that type of
demand for these breeds precisely
because of the aesthetic what I am
really concerned is you know we talk
about um
scrupulous breeders or we talk about
people who are doing it the right way
right uh and and God bless them and we
understand that they're doing them doing
it the right way but when there is such
an economic incentive for people to
breed these dogs with extreme features
um that is a concern for me that's a
powerful economic incentive and I was
really also um compelled by the
testimony we had from the vet who came
out I think it was from Rhode Island
right or Massachusetts he was not a
state vet uh but also from discussions
with uh my vet in Kean when I talked
about this she had some concerns that I
think the amendment addresses she
supported the idea behind it but was
concerned about some of the things that
as I said I think the amendment gets to
well so uh I also think that there is a
good reason to continue to study this
and to see if there is a way forward so
I would prefer interim study to itl
thank you representative
kraton thank you madam chair yeah my um
my personal vet who happens to me my
daughter explained that when she does
these surgeries they're they're pretty
horrific and and that she is uh
definitely opposed to the breeding of
dogs that that are tend to have these uh
conditions um but as we as we talked
about it and went through it uh a couple
of things occurred to me first of all
this build then would prohibit the sell
of these dogs
from um shelters and that type of thing
which then leads me to wonder what you
do with the dogs that are already in the
system uh and then um this the second
thing
was that
uh I'm just not sure that the Breeders I
I let me rephrase it I I'm convinced
that the Breeders and then AKC and other
organizations are uh much more attuned
to this just based on the volume of of
emails and volume of attention that we
got on this and so I think we have
pushed the ball pretty far forward into
their court and they've signed up to do
it and I think think that's where we
that's where we should leave it is is in
their hands over okay any other comment
representative sopak
kittis
um I also would support interim study
mom when you're a saying that you would
like a federal response to this I think
there's um a way for New Hampshire to be
a a trend Setter to give direction and
um feedback to our
delegation so that they could start to
do this I know that representative
kuster has um done a lot of work on the
agriculture committee down there and I
just think that we could take a
leadership role in this um even my dogs
Newland dogs are
um because of the ratio of what they say
these Breaky stalic dogs are if you if
you extrapolated out New Finland dogs St
Bernard dogs those dogs that drool a lot
those are also um these Breaky spyic
dogs um and so I think that if we make a
model um getting we can get together and
um discuss it and get a model
legislation for the rest of the nation I
I I I um support interim
study thank you um
oh representative ger thank you madam
chair I had remembered something
representative Katon rep representative
sopus uh jogged my memory of something
else that I wanted to to say that
addresses some of the things that they
also referred to um I hear what
representative kraton is saying about
the the Breeders my concern and again it
goes back to the testimony that's Pro
provided by the vet is that some of
these breeding standards are the problem
uh he referred to the use of extreme
right uh and other language that um is
really really disconcerting H so again I
think there's a financial incentive
that's really powerful here I think that
if we're going to the change has to come
at that level it certainly does but it's
not going to come unless there's
actually push back uh against these
organizations to tell them that those
literally by definition verbatim extreme
standards are not acceptable so that's
another reason why I would like to see
this uh at least have the possibility of
going forward thank you representative
Bixby uh so I was talking with uh a
couple of the folks who testified after
the uh hearing and one of the things
they pointed out is that uh current
breed standards with one exception in
the standard for I believe it's French
Bulldogs do not use the word extreme and
that it is current practice among
breeders to have testing for multiple
different genetically born conditions in
terms of which dogs they select for
breeding and that there is a move to uh
not breed to the extreme short muszle
length uh and so this this
is this is something that is developing
in the breeding world uh and that show
the fact that they're doing this shows
that they are responding to it there is
uh another Factor here which is that
there are those who breed for show there
are those who breed for for uh the pet
trade and uh the the one people who
breed for the pet trade may not feel as
constrained to do all of the testing uh
especially if they are large out of
state breeders who we've heard about in
other bills uh and uh the then the
question is what do we do about uh the
sourcing of animal of of of animals that
are are not uh that that have been bred
in in a less than ideal way or have
their initial raising in a less than
ideal way that's something that we have
discussed uh as you know and uh in in
regard to other bills and I think that
that is something we may want to look at
in the future uh looking at a broader
sense of how do we um how do we control
the sourcing of animals into our state
uh that may be coming from unscr
unscrupulous sources and I I think that
that uh that's something that needs to
be looked at is something that I don't
think is uh something we should do in a
study on this
bill representative H Haskins thank you
madam chair I appreciate uh
representative bixby's comments because
I think they augur in favor actually of
interim study I think we can help the
Breeders
in this effort to reduce the extreme
standards I think that we can as uh
representative sakita said um be out in
front on this issue that others may look
to us for um whatever we determine but
it seems to me this is the definition of
interim study the the issues that came
up are important to all of us and
therefore I think interim study is the
way to go thank you
represent
Penza okay so I was an itl and now I'm
leaning towards interm study and this is
the reason why and I I think what
representative H Haskins just said so
we've had all of these bills right that
have been um they've been killed on the
house floor that talk about sourcing and
the Pet Shop bill so if this bill goes
into interm study and we realize that
this can't be handled
legislatively and it's really a source
issue and maybe there's a pathway to do
it wouldn't that be the report that we
want to come
out any other comments representative
Howard thank you madam chair um I just
have questions about enforcement I I'm
not really sure um exactly at what point
um the we inter we intervene on behalf
animals thank you for that
um I'm going to support itl on this bill
I just think that
um from what the testimony I've heard
you know our the breeders in the state
have been conscientious in breeding
healthy
animals that seems to be uh you know
what they're interested in
um the um I think any health
issues um are are being continually
addressed by the Breeders and the
veterinarians in the state I don't
believe that we're we're seeing um any
of this extreme breeding going on uh nor
do we see complaints to the AG's
office um for for these kinds of extreme
uh breeding
activities and um I I think you know
we've got some responsible breeders um
working to
improve the health and um and look of
their
breeds um and with regard to
um you know
genetics I there's there's much that
breeders can't control when they're
doing uh their breeding
programs um and I just I I I just don't
think that this bill is is an
appropriate one representative kto thank
you madam chair although I appreciate
the intent of the
bill I don't uh believe believe um after
hearing all the
testimony um last week and asking the
question that nobody seems to be talking
about is environmental
impact and what we learned is that
although some breeds are more prone and
we may have nefarious breeders um what
we discovered is there really wasn't any
in the state and environmental impacts
really can
increase the health of these dogs
because if they become overweight that
affects their
breathing and as I had discussed I have
had uh a few of these breeds and had no
issues I've had uh large dogs that
weren't of of this type and a puppy
because I do believe
environmental factors
had some
issues and out of 30 puppies
one so I think we need to be
cognizant that um environmental
impact plays a huge role when someone
gets a dog or a
puppy any other discussion on this
bill I would ask now that the clerk call
the role represent thank you madam chair
the motion is itl on HB 1102
representative kraton I representative
coma yes representative D Simone yes
representative Davis yes representative
Thomas yes representative Bean yes
represent Kenny representative
Penza no represent smart represent Bixby
yes represent
sopus no represent Duty no represent
Murray yes represent jamana no represent
H Haskins nay represent Howard yes
represent NAB no represent Morris yes
itl 146 the motion
Report
okay yeah I'm going to close out the uh
1102 and I will now open the exact for
HB
1221 do I hear a
motion present
come thank you madam chair I would move
inim study do I hear a
second interim study represent
Katon would you like to speak to your
motion please representative K thank you
madam chair yes um I believe that we
heard discussion on this
and I think I know that my colleague has
an amendment which I also appreciate but
we still don't
know we haven't had testimony on that
and what the impacts of that would be
and I think with the passage of the
moratorium for
landfills that um and because with the
moratorium we could really take a dive
into this because this would exclude
existing
landfills this bill excludes existing
landfills and no landfill can be cited
until July 1
2028 which would give us time to really
delve in and see what the regional
impact fact is what the radius it what
radius it really should be with some
some study and bring forth the bill in
the fall that we've really delved
into representive
Katon thank you madam chair I I agree
with representive compa in the in the
questioning 10 miles versus 20 miles and
and the impact of that I think 10 miles
is better than 20 miles but is it the
right one I don't
know um but the other thing and if you
look at the bill and and this is what I
I don't understand under line 20 on page
number
one uh it says and you got excuse me a
second I had my eyes dilated this
morning so I'm focusing here um says the
local land used board Shell at the same
time submit an initial set of plans to
the regional Planning Commission the
cost of which is borne by the applicant
and so what I don't understand is that
this bill then requires the local
board to submit a plan I don't know what
that plan is I don't know it's submitted
to I don't know what it's based
on um and that that plan that they
create then goes back to the waste
facility Company to pay for that plan
which it just that confuses me I don't
understand and I may I may be missing
something but I I think an interim study
would help clear some of these
requirements up because now waste
management comes and says hey I want to
put this facility in oh by the way town
you have to create a plan for it and I
have to pay for that plan that you
create so I don't know if I'm misreading
that but I did it's I don't know to me
it's written in
English representative Bixby yeah but m
mam chair um I believe that uh
representative Katon is discussing the
amendment and I'm not sure that we all
have copies of that yeah I have them
sure can you pass it pass it out fair
you I do want to make a comment um to
representative gerana that I appreciate
all the work that he put into um putting
this amendment together uh and working
with representative grassy on it
um I I do also have a
concern regarding this particular bill
as it relates to Regional impact I
received an email this morning from a
constituent um of mine in
aworth and um he said I I'm writing
quickly on hb1 1221 a bill have to do
with the definition of development of
regional impact which your committee is
scheduled to EXA today the underlying
issue has to do with 15 or so towns in
New Hampshire without zoning I wondered
whether RAC tracks might also be subject
to a determination of developments of
regional impact and and so you know
while I understand this
particular bill is talking about Solid
Waste
landfills I I would would like to have a
little bit more time to study this to
see how it would re relate to other
projects um that are being considered in
a particular area of the state um and if
if this is setting any sort of precedent
that might
be utilized to prevent projects which
might be good projects from being
brought uh into different places of the
state so I I I kind of would like to
have a little bit of time to um to study
the issue of what are we what are we
talking about when we're talking about
Regional impact do we just limit it to
Solid Waste landfills or should we talk
about uh you know other things going
on representative ger thank you madam
chair and I appreciate your your
previous comments uh I I think looking
at RSA
3654 talking about the the purpose of
this chapter uh in RSA the purpose of
the subdivision is to provide timely
notice to potentially affected
municipalities concerning proposed
developments which are likely to have
impacts beyond the boundaries of a
single municipality uh and looking at
the the rest of the chapter here uh in
my mind this is uh exactly what this
statute exists to do we're adding
landfills in among other kinds of
projects in the state that by definition
have a have a regional impact uh we have
as as the chairwoman pointed out uh we
have made some changes in the amendment
that that we've circulated here that
brings it down to 10 miles 10 miles and
if if possible perhaps representative
grassy could speak to this uh bringing
it under that is simply not going to be
uh effective and so we brought it down
to the mile distance that was kind of
the minimum distance that would
genuinely be effective we talked about
15 but 10 is as far as we could bring it
down and I have a sense looking at the
watersheds that it would actually be a
meaningful change uh representative
Grassi also worked with Mr deer at Dees
to make sure that we had the right
Watershed map uh so that we are using
the data uh and the map that Dees would
be using as they were looking at these
watersheds so uh I as I said I I believe
that this fits squarely into the chapter
as it currently exists it was for Purp
purposes like this that this chapter I
think was written fits perfectly so I
hear what uh what Madam chair is saying
about whether or not there might be
other kinds of projects that would be
suitable I think that's a good question
but I don't think that question should
be uh should limit us from taking action
in a case where you know we clearly can
identify it and I don't know Madam chair
if if we might ask representative grassy
um who has spoken directly with Dees on
some of these issues if he could click
clarify some of the questions not at
this
time okay so I I think that again that's
what the statute was written for we're
adding landfills is clearly uh these are
projects that have Regional uh impact by
development uh by definition I'm sorry
uh and I think we should move forward
okay representative Bixby yeah so um
there there the the question of whether
Mission creep is possible and whether
this would encourage it uh any
other uh any other facility or type of
uh of development that someone was
concerned about could be a proposed as a
bill whether or not we do we pass this
uh so uh that is so essentially this is
uh this is really has a very specific
Focus which is uh landfill Solid Waste
landfills that
uh would be large enough to have a
regional impact and uh so the so um I
think that this bill is very very
clearly targeted uh I think that the um
I I think that the 10 Mile boundary
makes a lot of sense I think that I
really appreciate uh uh getting the uh
Watershed map that very very clearly
defines the smaller size of watersheds
that would be uh used in order to make
the determination here uh
and uh in terms of uh what's required to
be uh done for notification that the
notification is done to
municipalities and for the out of state
is done to the Secretary of State those
that's a very small number of
notifications uh so
uh and uh so I think that uh this is
very reasonable in terms of what it
proposes it
also covers the territory very
thoroughly I I think that the question
is do we think notification is an
appropriate action in which case we
should pass this or do we think that an
that notification is an inappropriate
action in which case we should itl it I
don't think there's anything here to
study representative hins thank you
madam chair
um this is a very important bill and a
lot of work has gone into it we can't
solve all of our Solid Waste problems
easily or overnight but this is one step
toward getting us to recognize the
impact that landfills have on the area
around them for instance Whitefield and
Littleton and places that are not in the
town town where a landfill might be
built so with respect I don't I don't
think we need to study it I think we
know why we need it and this is almost
um helping a an Omission that now that
we understand the impact that landfills
have on the region around them we can
simply insert them in the bill in the
law that we already have thank you okay
representative
smart thank you madam chair um
I I I don't I guess I don't understand
if we have a bill that we have have
decided it's been passed that we're
going to wait and we have a moratorium
on landfill any landfill decisions
because we're trying to get it right why
would we pass something that has
something to do with landfill now when
we haven't got all the information to
get everything right we have a portion
of information so why can't this go into
the the landfill
bill when we finally come up with
one am I making that everybody looks
puzzled I I don't know that we have any
other Bill well didn't didn't we say we
were G to put a moratorium on any
landfills for till
2028 that's that's past the house yes
right and so Dees was going to WR rules
that's what we're waiting for not
another bill okay so why can't this go
in with that why do we have to decide on
something now why not itl it yeah
represent
Penza so this isn't this isn't a
landfill bill this is really a a like a
public notice bill um I don't think it
needs to be studied uh if everybody's
read you know um
3655 it's pretty clear it's a very small
um Regional planning commission's
statement and it has there you know
proximity to borders of a neighboring
Community anticipated emissions such as
light noise smoke odors particles
proximity to aquifers or surface waters
which transcend Municipal boundaries
shared facilities such as schools and
solid waste disposal facilities so how
this was first put out I could not
support but how it's put now which I
think appeases many on my side of the
aisle where you know current landfill
operations are exempt from this um and
this is really a notice um 10 miles you
know I don't I that's the one piece that
I will agree I think it was
representative I'm not sure which
representative said that you know what
the miles is I'm very happy that the
Watershed um was discussed specifically
with Dees so they've confirmed that we
have correct information um you know I
think there's an opportunity for this to
pass our body but not the other one and
uh I I think we should move forward with
this it's really about public
notice representative
Morris thank you madam chair um I would
just like to really sort of agree with
representative Penza on this and as a
planning board member who frequently
deals with uh Regional impact
notifications this is very
straightforward this is stuff that we do
frequently we have a process it it this
just allows us to make sure that our
communities are aware make sure that
people who you know might need to have
some sort of involvement in the process
are notified and involved and I I think
that um if you don't have experience
with that these can all seem very
confusing and hard to understand but um
those who serve on planning commissions
and those who you know frequently do
Regional impacts this this is very
straightforward I I support you know PPA
on this okay representative
Howard um it seems the fear of the of
what um representative Bixby calls a
mission creep um if if this were to be
appli applied to noise in in a region
rather than rather than um water
underground I I don't think that would
be I don't think that's a big risk right
now I I think that it's probably
something that you'd want to talk about
representative Murray thank you madam
chair I also um will not be supporting
interim study I I think that this is um
in this current motion I think that this
is
um appropriate as representative Moore
said I also think that when we're asking
for regional impact um notifications um
like representative Moore said this
happens all the time when we see
Department of Transportation
notifications or 10year planning
commissions come before um local um
zoning commissions or boards um we see
that um so yes I um agree that this is
just more of a notification sort of
circumstance okay thank you
representative ktoa thank you madam
chair it's not about the notification
it's just for me I haven't heard any
information we talked about the
Watershed we talked about the original
mile range but I don't know what the
impact of this one is and for me that's
the question I don't
know so that's why I'm asking for that
because I haven't heard any testimony
regarding the 10 mile radius is
basically what it is it is a radius so
that is my question just I want to
clarify that for everyone because I
don't know what the impact is I haven't
seen a map on that and I really would
like to know
Madam chair would it be okay if I asked
rep Morris a question based on her
planning board experience sure
absolutely so looking at did you get a
chance to look at that sentence that I
put on that I I highlighted at the
21 the local lamb board shell yeah what
are your thoughts on that
so basically this is a fairly
straightforward way that this
um my planning board deals with a lot of
uh subdivisions right so we have to take
a look at those subdivisions and say
does this have Regional impact is it is
it bordering on a lot that touches one
of the other towns in our area and so it
is always the responsibility of the
person who is doing the subdivision or
suggesting you know that they're going
to bring in some sort of development or
anything like that they will be
responsible for um paying for any kind
of notification any kind of surveys any
of those things so my understanding of
this is that it falls in line with
basically all of the um notifications
Regional impact everything that I'm
involved with on my planning board I'm
also um in close contact with our
regional Lake sunap Upper Valley
Regional Planning Commission whatever it
is um and it all pretty much functions
the same way because of the rsas that
already exist that have been cited in in
this amendment so it doesn't in my
opinion cause any confusion to the
people who are um going to be doing the
work as well as um you know when we're
talking about setbacks and those things
to sort of go back to representative K's
question it's it's really just saying
within this amount of space could there
be an impact to this
community's resources in in whatever way
whether it's you know a watershed or a
lake or any of these other things these
are these are just things that uh the
planning board we sit through we look at
all of these different things we ask
questions and then we vote to decide is
this something that we need to address
as Regional impact and this just gives a
little bit more guidance for those
boards and committees to be able to say
okay this this does require that we
notify
someone quick followup should quick
followup and then I have a question for
representative ger and so okay just to
be clear then so when it says that it
directs the planning board to come up
with a plan which is additional work but
you normally expect that to happen
absolutely okay yeah we're we're all
completely prepared to to take on any
additional work that requires any
planning we have resources and people
that we normally work with to address
any of those concerns okay thank you
sure so I have a question for
representative ger and so far as um we
are sticking in this paragraph or
section three into RSA 36 colon 56 which
is review of developments of regional
impact and so what we're adding in is
that located with any Watershed as
defined by the eight digigit hydrologic
units from the national hydrography data
set 2011 and as may be from time to time
amended where such landfill may be
proposed if outside the Watershed
located within 10 miles and so that we
are saying all proposed Solid Waste
landfills shall be projects of regional
impact and notice shall be made to the
all
communities located within New Hampshire
so that the regional Planning
Commission isn't making that
notice but it's being put in their
that who's the notification I thought
was coming from the landfill people it
is okay it is too and and I would also I
thank you if I may also in part of
respon response to your question Madam
chair and with reference to um some of
the very enlightening information that
representative Morris has been giving us
um if people have looked at you know
3657 this goes down a little bit in
terms of that notification process and
then the work done by the regional
planning boards that is already as is
indicated even in this amendment's
language right that's already part of
law right so this is already something
that is required by law it's done by our
planning boards in this case we're
making sure that the applicant um well
actually that's already the cost that
shall be borne by the applicant is is
already there what we're adding to law
proposing to add to law is uh notifying
the Secretary of State of another
bordering state uh that was uh some
discussion we had had before right about
the difficulties potentially of knowing
who to notify if it's out of state so
this is just you send it to one place
and then let them figure out how to how
to notify uh but I think that your
interpretation of the the previous
section is correct it's it's the uh
applicants job to provide the
notification and then the process
proceeds from there based on what's
mostly already in law in 3657 thank you
representative
Penza so I just wanted to respond to
representative Comas um because I I can
understand this is you know there's a
little bit of confusion but it's
basically to me all of the stuff is
already in statute and law and it's just
um notifying just it's so let's say if
it's currently they're notifying this
it's going out to here that's it so it's
just getting more voters informed and
the reason why I support this is because
of Rochester so and we have a landfill
there and um and I'm going to be
supportive of them expanding because um
it's it's it's going to be necessary um
and they're doing things the right way
they're very good at notifying um but
where they're located in Rochester right
now in their abutters is is very narrow
and you have to understand that
literally a Stones Throw is do for them
and so this really and then there's all
barington and all the that that are
really affected by this and I think
everybody should know kind of what's
Happening you know having a local
election that I was working at um in Lee
and Madbury and do W 4 uh over the past
week um I can't tell you how many voters
just don't know they don't know they're
it's really hard and just a notice in
the paper is hard so I think um sending
out you know direct letters to people's
homes I I don't think it's much to ask
um I really I I like this bill okay
represent kto thank you madam chair may
ask representative Penza this would not
all if they're expanding it would not
they're not that no it won't but they're
still going to do the same thing that
they already do which is in their
Butters and all of that but I can tell
you right now because of stuff that's
going on in Rochester they are
automatically um doing more Outreach I
have to give them that um they want to
really handle the concerns there's huge
odor concerns that we have um this um
the amount of of rain that we've had is
really affecting their operations um
they've a phenomenal job so um yes it
doesn't affect them because they
wouldn't have to they would be
grandfathered in in a sense okay all
right um one more representative Murray
and then we should call the vote I think
I to that point I think that with
respect to um the am the amendment that
was proposed I I want to make sure that
we're to represent a potental point we
are not
um this is a service that is provided to
our community to deal with the TR that
our communities create right and so in
doing so when we have to then think
about impacts in our communities just
like many other types of things that are
Regional in nature a landfill is
regional and so I think this makes
pragmatic sense to move forward in that
way all right so um I guess I'll have
representative Conta call the RO on the
motion of interim study thank you madam
chair uh represent kraton I represent K
yes represent D Simone yes represent
Davis yes represent Thomas yes represent
Bean yes represent Kenny represent Penza
no represent smart yes represent Bixby
no represent
sopus no represent Duty no represent
Murray no represent Jama no represent H
Haskins nay represent Howard no
represent NAB no repr Morris no
yes 911 motion
fails okay do I hear any
other motion representa Gera thank you
madam chair um I
move I can move the amendment first
right before move the amendment now
adoption adopt the amendment thank you
uh I move to adopt Amendment uh
2024 101027
H I hear second representative NAB I'll
second the motion okay representative
ger do I hear uh would you uh speak to
your motion please yes thank you madam
chair uh I think most of you know we've
talked about this amendment already in
our discussion a previous discussion uh
we really tried to uh take in questions
and concerns that uh came up from
members uh on both sides in our previous
discussion uh and went back to Dees and
and did things like making sure we had
the right Watershed um I understand the
10 miles there for some folks there's a
question about what that is our sense
was that anything less than that is
simply not going to be uh sufficient and
here we are talking about uh just
letting uh informing communities within
that range uh of these potential
projects uh we also have the
grandfathering Clause that was a
response to some questions that were
raised uh at that time so um I feel like
we did a responsible job in coming up
with a a compromise document I for one
actually am not a fan of grandfathering
in um existing sites I would say if if
you have an an expansion that it should
go through this process uh but again
that's something we gave up on because
we heard from members of the committee
and wanted to put together an amendment
that incorporated all of those concerns
so uh that's all I have to say about it
at this point so thank you any further
discussion
well um go ahead representative uh
kraton no thank you ma'am and uh I I
want to thank rep Morris who answered
the question and clarified some stuff
from me anyway and uh J for work on the
amendment uh I would like to Echo that
thank you representative Morris and I
want to thank representative ger also
for um for his work on on putting this
amendment together and I will also be
supporting
it so with that um representative K
would you call the role yeah this is to
adopt Amendment 202 24-10 27h represent
kraton I represent K yes represent D
Simone yes represent Davis yes represent
Thomas yes represent Bean yes represent
Kenny yes represent Penza yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent s
Aus yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins I representative Howard yes
represent NAB yes represent Morris yes
represent bman yes Madam chair yes 20
the amendment is adopted
wonderful do I hear another
representative ger thank you uh I move
otpa on HB
1221 representative seconds would you
like to speak to your um motion uh no
thank you madam chair I think it's all
been said okay then I would direct the
uh clerk to call the
role uh the motion is otpa uh represent
cron I represent ktoa yes represent D
Simone yes represent Davis yes represent
Thomas yes represent Bean yes represent
Kenny represent Penza yes represent
smart represent Bixby yes represent
sopus yes represent Duty yes represent
Murray yes represent Jam yes represent H
Haskins I represent Howard represent NAB
yes represent Moors yes represent ban
yes Madam chair yes 20 shall It Go on
consent
yes okay um I'm going to close out uh
with my gavel if I find it here close
out the exec for um hb1
1221 and we have finished with our exec
session uh 15 minutes
early I want to thank our committee for
um a very good um interesting discussion
and
um thoughts of of of uh speaking back
and forth and willing to listen on this
last bill um and I'm very pleased with
uh how we all turned out so thank you I
take a little
bit I'm sorry yeah and I will remind
everybody for uh getting those committee
reports to me please and representative
dsy you have the Minority Report for the
bracky bill yup so I want to thank
everybody take a break and we'll be back
at
11:30
e
uh take their seats please we're going
session a little bit past 11:30 here
we're running
late I okay so um we are going to uh
open some discussion on hb1 1574 for uh
bill that we heard last week um removing
regulations on the direct sale of raw
milk and consumers to
Consumers um that's HB
1574 and I open up any discussion from
our committee regarding uh testimony and
uh the bill in
general representative kraton oh yes
ma'am yeah sponsor did not show oh for
the raw milk bill yeah Ah that's true
and and the fign bureau was against it
and dhss was against it and so that to
me was sort of compelling yeah
representative Duty uh yes I mean we
just had a bill similar to this uh I
believe it was last session and we had
talked about I think we had raised it at
that point to 20 gallons I'm not sure
perhaps one of the other Representatives
has a better re recall than I do but I
would be adverse to making another
change to this representative Kaman did
you I thought okay yeah um I think you
know we've kind of discussed raw milk to
death the past two years three years
four years um and I think that the the
changes that we made to statute at that
time were uh reasonable un workable um
we're still we're still seeing the
results of that
and I think
um I I I I don't see any real reason to
pursue any further uh expansion of uh
the production or sale of raw milk and
so I would be itl on this bill
representative Bixby so uh at the
hearing uh last week I um we were on the
verge of saying should we exec this
right now itl and I and I said no
because we have a couple of people on
the committee who might want to voice
some other opinion but those people are
not here today so I think that uh we
know what to do with this
bill
okay uh representative ktoa thank you
madam chair um the prime sponsor
apologizes for not being here he did
reach out to me um and he understands
that the bill as written is is a no-o
um I explained to him especially where
in regards to the ice cream
um that that container size is there for
a very specific reason um and it's
extremely important that we keep that
size and statute but he did ask if we
could make a modest increase to the
gallons of say like f an increase from
20 gallons to 25 gallons so I'm just
going to put that out there for the
committee
okay any other comments on
this all right well I guess um uh we we
will be uh executing this bill next week
along with several others and uh I guess
we'll move on to discussions on uh
hp504 relative to architectural paint
recycling and I will give the floor to
representative Murray who will uh update
us on what her sub subcommittee has been
working on and uh any other comments she
has uh on on this bill uh thank you
madam chair um since the last we met um
you had just asked for an update um on
some things and so this is an
opportunity for the full sub um full
committee to also work on this together
I've given you a copy of potential um
thoughts and language around the
structure of the bill um we had heard
from the Department um at uh last week
sometime oh I'm sorry did you oh sorry
sorry um about some concerns that they
had had around um paint being classified
when you're at the regular big box
retailer as hazardous waste and the
potential of when it would be um
returned to either a collection site
whether it's a a political subdivision
like a transport station or some other
municipally run collection site um it
would be still considered hazardous
waste so there was some conversation
about um making sure that there was a
provision for what is called Universal
waste and um that is something that I
did include in sort of my my thoughts in
the sort of um drafting of the document
and I apologize for there not being um
page we're double-sided here one two
three four five six it would be seven so
the last page of the stapled paperwork
um there's a Ru making procedure and the
department um May adopt rules or
procedures to implement the requirements
of the the subdivision or chapter
Universe W uh waste designation for
postc Consumer
paint um and that would just have a
clear defined role for how the paint is
considered one of the things that it
would also require in this sort of
chapter of universal waste is that they
are clearly labeled I sort of I very
boldly um highlighted for our
subcommittees consideration today a
statement that says under sub paragraph
C that containers holding postc consumer
paint that is regulated as universal
waste shall be clearly labeled as
universal waste paint used paint or
waste paint and that is something that
um I think um the department had just
briefly touched on but I don't know are
they available to come up and provide
conversation during this sub committee
um during a work session yeah they would
be' be happy to have comment on it and
that was just yeah that was just the one
thing that I I wanted you to explain a
little bit more about your desires of
waste I want to remind everyone please
to um when you're speaking to make sure
your microphone is on uh I've had an
email from someone saying that they are
listening in and uh we are not always
putting our microphones on so just just
that go right ahead and hi Todd pisit
with the new New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and with the
Hazardous Waste Management Bureau and I
did have concerns oilbased paint in New
Hampshire is is classified as hazardous
waste solvent-based paints also are
classified as hazardous waste um when a
homeowner has these things household
hazardous waste is exempt from that
however as soon as it's collected by
another entity it then must it then
becomes hazardous waste and has to be
handled as as such other states have
have designated oilbased paints as
universal waste which is something we
have the ability to do in New Hampshire
Universal waste is still uh a type of
hazardous waste but there are far less
strict requirements on how it's managed
and an entity that only collects
Universal waste would not necessarily be
a hazardous waste generator whereas if
you took in this oilbased paint and it
wasn't classified as universal waste
that entity that took it in an AC
Hardware or something like that would
become a hazardous waste generator would
have to notify would have to follow all
the rules within the Hazardous Waste
rules so making it a universal waste
would help with that um there are still
concerns as far as hazardous waste is
concerned because uh it it seems
that occasionally nonprogrammed
materials get brought to these locations
so if something like paint thinner which
isn't part of the program gets collected
that that's hazardous waste and becomes
hazardous waste so it's it's unclear how
that would be managed but by designated
designated oilbased and Sol
solvent-based paints as universal waste
would would go a long way to making that
sort of go away that that concern okay
and is that's something that can be
accommodated in in any amendment to this
Bill yes and I I am also working with
some other stakeholders about that
specific sort of concern that the
department was mentioning around like
all other solvents what to do with those
in the in the circumstance where that
happens yes so okay um and if I may um
sure go right ahead one of the other
things that um I had taken a look at the
fee structures associated with other
states and if you look at the paint here
um sheet that you have that's a
double-sided one dated January
2024 it does look like there were some
updates made to structures in the state
of Vermont to keep up with um the
ability to manage the program and then
also um there were structures with uh
respect to those smaller than one gallon
one to two gallons and up to uh um up to
five gallon buckets so the fee structure
went from I believe it was initially
$1.99 through uh April of 2024 so we
haven't crushed that well Vermont has
not crushed that threshold yet and they
are slated to then adjust them beginning
May one um to
$245 and a do35 for one to two gallons
and 65 cents um for less than one gallon
of paint so um one of the other types
one of the other things and being
careful that we were not putting an
undue burden on the department was to
ensure that there was the potential to
have a portion of the fees go to the
department and so on the very last last
page on the rear side I had 15 to 30
cents of each fee going to the
department for ongoing review oversight
management of the program on an annual
basis I don't know if that's the right
number yet I that is just something that
I had started off uh looking at sort of
if we had collected a 100,000 gallons of
paint within the state annually based on
sort of the averages of the data we saw
previously among similarly sized States
like Rhode Island Vermont Maine um if
you know what what that number looked
like so I want to be more careful in
thinking about you know that what is it
25 cents is it 50 cents is it what is
that what is that number that would be
appropriate do we know if other states
use a portion of their fee for for the
similar support of their Environmental
Services Division that deals with it I
don't know that's a great question I can
certainly look at that I think
representative Duty so and then
yeah yeah I'm I I can't answer that
directly but it was my understanding
that the way paint care works is that
they handle all of the um the the fees
um in in the process and that any work
that is to be done by Dees oversight
reviewing plans that they actually pay
um the department for um the services
that they provide so that that was my
understanding when and I was more
involved in this you know just a couple
of months ago so um I think that's one
thing we might want to check out okay so
so walk me through the process of how
this
works oh okay I'm sorry I would just
reiterate what representative Duty says
I believe I don't have the statute in
front of me but new Vermont's statute at
the very end has uh um a fee that paint
care would pay to the Department to
cover their costs
okay may I did look at that fee
structure it's enumerated in their rules
subdivision it's not in statute from my
understanding so I have to and I let me
just I don't mean to let me double check
because I was I was looking at both
Maine and Vermont and I think it was
enumerated in
rules but it may be but I spoke with
Vermont and I don't think they made
rules I think they just went they just
stuck with a statute but like I said I
don't have the statute okay
so okay yeah so walk me through what
happens somebody goes into a paint store
buys some paint and so when they check
out whether the the this is what we were
talking about representative Duty and I
were debating whether or not the fee is
already baked in if you will to the
actual cost of the paint and in some
circumstances that's the case and there
are other states who had an added user
fee on at the end at the check check te
sand so like for example in places where
you buy milk and you have a glass
container deposit that is M charged um
those types of fees are there as well so
there were two models that have have
that but most of the paint care models
have it already sort of in the back end
of the program like worked into the
structure and that is then
withheld okay representative
comtable thank you madam chair and uh
thank you repres Murray for working on
this
um so how will this affect retailers
regarding paperwor and getting the
Monies
to where they need to go so is this like
another step like um you know we have R
rooms and males tax right so you have to
separate that out and you have to file a
report what would this what kind of
uh added paperwork would this do add on
to businesses I guess my question I
think that that's exactly why paint care
manages and oversees it that information
then goes through paint Care's program
and paint care then distributes that
information and data uh in conjunction
with uh the department and that's why
that that fee for the Department to then
look at those things there's a whole
bunch of antitrust sort of conversations
in here as well because there is monies
being collected there has to be a
requirement in here to make sure that
there are there's a thirdparty verifier
of the program um to look at that fee
structure when you're dealing with money
um that is listed inside of what I'm
proposing representative dsy uh yes I I
think the way I mean it's it's all
automated so for example I mean every
time you go to the store and they scan
what you're buying I mean all that gets
computed and it gets into um gets into a
report so I mean I would assume that the
retailers Maybe on a monthly basis would
generate a report to paint care saying
we sold 100 you know 100 gallons of XYZ
uh you know uh 20 pints of XYZ and then
based on that and based on what the fees
are it it's just calculated out so I
mean I think it's already part of their
inventory control systems that are
automated so then on the other end when
you're finished with your painting
project and you have half a gallon of
paint left over you bring it back to the
retailer you purchased it from is that
what I'm hearing you can do that or
there can be um collection sites
established at places like transfer
stations so there could be an either or
okay
so then you you go and you drop off your
paint but you're not getting any money
back for it at all nothing you're just
you're just disposing of it there
instead of throwing it in your own trash
with the kitty litter or whatever and so
then they the retailer then works it out
with paint cares
to quote unquote recycle the paint right
and there are there's a little bit more
information on the front and the back of
the different um structures that paint
care has on this this one pager so to
speak um of what their sort of business
what their model is for the program um
for businesses to be able to to plug
into this for contractors to be able to
make sure that they're working on
including this in their estimate so that
they're not losing Revenue either like
if there's somebody painting someone's
home how are they then adjusting for
this as well so there's all sorts of
things in here um as far as educational
materials to uh retailers and
contractors do all retailers have to
participate in this the way this is
currently written it does say shall but
I I that is why I opened the discussion
up to um having the ability for smaller
municipal entities to have the ability
to take them back because when we were
talking I think in our subcommittee one
of the discussions um was about well
what happens if there isn't one nearby
me what do I do then right and so how do
we Empower our local municipalities to
say okay I'm willing to take this on I
think we had
um Sarah speak to that um in her
community and I think it could be
replicated elsewhere as well um I don't
know Sarah did you wan to do you have
additional thank you for the question I
actually went up to Vermont and in
Burlington and saw their program up
there and uh as a hazardous waste
program I take only the oilbased paint
now but under the paint CARE program I
would also take the latex only I would
not be responsible for paying for all of
that disposal and it's one of our
biggest uh Products that come in paint
care would take care of sending a waste
holler to come and pick it up and remove
it from my hazardous waste facility and
I believe it would be the same process
if it was like Home Depot or some little
paint store in a small town they would
collect it at their place and the paint
care people would come down and send
someone there a waste huler to remove it
and this would be possible if it to for
them the little retailer to take the
oilbased paint as well as latex if it
was a universal waste like uh some
Mercury objects and antifreeze and I'm
sure yes can explain that better than I
representative
Katon you guys may to whoever can answer
this question I know does this include
polyurethane varnish shellac or is it
just oilbased
come on
up I'm not sure how that goes into
spending hundreds of hours in my wood
shop it it sort of strikes me
as I can't actually answer that question
I don't I'm not I'm not no I can't can
I'm not exactly sure whether poer things
I don't believe they would be covered
okay um but I'd have to look more into
that um I will just to get to the just
to also weigh in on on the collection
facilities I talked to Vermont and they
they said that a lot of their transfer
stations do it a lot of retailers do it
but the big box stores Home Depot Lowe's
and Walmart don't they have to
participate in that they collect the
fees but they don't have to participate
by being a takeback station so the big
box stores don't do it but sh Sherwin
Williams and Benjamin Moore stores do in
MH in Vermont I know they took some
stains some stains contain polyurethane
some do not but I can't Enlighten you
anymore on that as well okay thank you
I'm wondering if that's something I can
get clarified through paint care too as
well as yeah yeah so represent Howard
this may be an ignorant question but is
this only is this only liquid paint or
cans well I think that um that's a fair
fair point when when the I don't want to
let me
clarify um but I I do know that even
just talking with um some folks this
morning you know
um whether you have like an eighth of a
gallon left or like whatever it is you
know folks traditionally are are either
pouring it out and letting it dry and
then adding it back into it uh their you
know into their landfilling waste so to
speak and I think that um there are like
situations where paint ding can be re
like through through solent re
reawakened I guess you want to say uh to
be reconstituted and reused but I'm I I
can find out an answer to
that okay represent dsy uh yeah uh my
understanding is that it would only be
the liquid paint because basically what
they're doing is they're mixing it
together and and recycling it so so
basically the recycled paint is going to
be given away to like nonprofits sold at
a discount um you know that type of
thing and if you have an empty paint can
or you had a dried paint can then that
can just be thrown into the um uh
landfill okay so that's not a problem
although last year I did do that I
opened up a some paint and let it dry it
took about six to eight months a year
takes a long time for paint to dry when
it's in a
can but but otherwise I would imagine
the can itself could be recycled in the
metal bin or whatever you could put as
me as a metal
can as the paint dries it shrinks so you
could probably just dump that out and
yeah probably representative NAB thank
you madam chair I just um look to answer
representative kryton's question on the
paint care website it says they accept
primer stained sealers and clear coting
such such as shellac and
barnish it says yes yeah represent H
Haskins Madam chair um Miss Sarah has a
point and would you identify yourself
please yes I'm Sarah silk from wol New
Hampshire I've run that Lakes Region
household Hazard product facility for 35
years towns of Alton and wolfboro
members and we take anyone from anywhere
on a fee basis we take um liquid paint
uh several of the representatives here
have mentioned if it's a latex paint or
an oilbased paint and it's totally hard
in the can then that goes to Solid Waste
the recycled paint is the latex paint
which they add mil aside and other
things to to make it new they don't
recycle the oilbased paint into paint
they sell to anybody that comes by like
up at the program in Burlington the only
thing that they reprocess is the latex
not the oil base that always goes with a
waste
huler like it's hazardous waste all
right thank you for that um so for me
before going back to your comment about
um a May versus a sh in so far as um
participating retailers participating in
the
program um I I'd prefer to see a May
instead of a sh in there because first
of all this this is going to be kind of
a pilot program it's going to be uh
something that um once once the public
finds out about this they may uh want to
seek out retailers specifically that are
doing this and as it becomes more
popular
um I think you know it'll it'll it won't
need a sh you know representative Bixby
yeah I think that in talking about the
participation I think that uh the in
terms of uh accepting the paint back or
except uh or or or being a drop off site
I think that that should be a May uh
because um I I thinking that uh not I'm
thinking there there are two possible
uh groups here that might not want to
participate one are the very large box
retailers which we've heard testimony
that they tend not to the other is uh
are uh very few remaining uh really
independent uh hardware stores might not
have the capacity to do this uh and and
I I know that uh it's been cited that
the Ace Hardwares and the Sherman
Williams are already participating and
that's you know it's great that they're
doing that but um in the states where
this is a thing uh in terms of uh but
there's the other aspect of it is in
terms of paying the uh of adding the fee
to the price of the paint and I think
that one should be a sh
agre okay represent dsy and then kraton
yeah the only question that I had and
this was in the original bill um I
didn't read anything about what we do
about the existing paint cans that we
have in our our basement um because I
would assume that that there was not a
fee Associated to them when we bought
them like 10 or 15 years ago you know so
is there some provision that I can take
them back um and pay a $2 fee or is it
just assumed that you know eventually
these Legacy can are going to be taken
back U representative kraton and then
you
guys thank you madam
chair this thing makes a lot of sense to
me
um the one question about the May versus
shell is that okay so I pay a buck a
gallon to have this program in the state
that makes sense but if I live in antrum
and I have to travel 30 miles to find a
facility that actually takes it then why
am I pay in a buck to do
that yeah go ahead representative to
your point representative I think that
that's why we're saying that this can
either be a major retailer or a transfer
station or some other entity that
receives them so that there aren't large
distances for people to travel where
there isn't an opportunity okay Madam
shair follow and so how do I know that
the
Anum recycle or the the antrum dump will
be able to do that or is GNA do that
that's a great Point um so because I
don't have access to Hillsboro right or
Bennington or any other Town yes ma'am
I'm sorry sure yes thank you madam chair
um so yes uh also within this the
department um has the ability to post on
their website where these locations are
and so um if that's what you're saying
when you're looking for a and paint care
can provide a list to the Department of
where those sites are throughout the
state is that what you're
asking go
ahead no my point is that I go down to
Edmond's Hardware which I do like every
day and I buy paint which I do all the
time and I pay an extra Buck for a
gallon and I'm willing to do that but
the Anum transfer station doesn't take
it and I live in the middle of nowhere
and so if Edmond doesn't take it then
who
does and do I have to travel 30 miles to
get there if the Anum transfer station
because I'm not allowed to go to
Hillsboro I'm not allowed to go to B I
have the
sticker no I understand and I appreciate
that thank you I appreciate that
representative Duty I just want to
interject if you go up on paint care and
look at Vermont and look at all of the
drop off stations okay the little things
I mean it covers the whole state you
know so so I mean um the the chances of
you having to drive 30 miles I think
would be very slim even you know like up
north in the rural parts of it so I
think that's a good place to start yeah
okay thank you represent Bixby okay so
in terms of um Municipal whether
municipalities have uh May or shall
participate in this is is there anything
uh in the the draft at this point that
says that um a transportation or a or a
City Recycling um program um May or
shall do this
yes so I I I did say on page three
um section five when we're talking about
geographic
information it says one additional U
permanent site will be established for
every 10,000 residents we talked about
um the residency requirement and then it
says unless otherwise approved by the
department these sites may be run by
political subdivisions such as transfer
stations I'm willing this is a draft
like I'm willing to put in there
anything else that would make you know
if it's if it's preferable that it is a
shell so that we have the ability for
folks in rural communities to be able to
do that and then call up paint care and
say hey my friends we have our we have
our stuff that needs picked up can you
send a hauler please um I think that
that makes sense if you prefer for it to
be a shall I'm happy to do that I'm
yes okay representative Howard and then
Penza um two two things about the fees
one of them is um one is a suggestion
one the other's a question so if if we
say um may we could may we could attach
a an incentive to that um but also I
wonder as far as these feeds go do they
all go to the plan and nothing goes to
vendor representative Bixby uh I believe
the way that it works is that um all of
the fees are uh go to the are basically
processed by the paint CARE program and
if the vendor is running a pickup
station then the vendor would get the um
get appropriate payment in order to
handle that uh if they are not doing
pickup then they you then they they
would just pass the fees on to pain care
and not get anything back uh and if the
uh is that correct right and that was my
and that is where my discussion enters
into the conversation about should there
be a small portion of the fee reserved
for the Department to be able to do some
of the ongoing oversight management of
this so it's not an undue burden to them
and if that needs to happen then how do
I um my my conversation with paint care
is how do I structure that so that's
that's really my question for paint care
okay um let me get representative Penza
and then you so just kind of following
up with what representative Duty asked
so if you because I I don't have it now
but we did so if you have a whole bunch
of old paint it just seems like
everybody does right and it's hanging
out in their garage if they don't hit
that one day of the year where it comes
where they um some cities municipalities
and towns have a
pickup is there a point where that paint
unusable I have that question down to
ask with with folks to make sure that we
can deal with the Legacy paint concern
Bixby I have a question for the
Department um so uh are there uh are
there th under department rules are
there things that uh transfer stations
are required to cover in their in what
they accept as
trash well that's more of a solid waste
question and I'm in hazardous waste so
what's in their permit what's in their
Solid Waste permit and actually Sarah
could probably answer that more directly
than I
could yep go ahead a actually um I don't
actually deal with solid waste I was a
selectman for 13 years but I can tell
you I get tons of calls from the city of
lonia because they do not take any type
of mercury light bulbs in the whatever
contract they have with their waste
holler which I think is waste management
but they may have changed we take it
because we belong and Alton takes them
along with a lot of other Universal Wast
because we belong to NR and it's a
monetary advantage to belong to the NRA
programs so so I don't think that um
towns are required to take all waist
streams personally I think they should
because then it's a burden if someone
has an apartment building for example
and wants to get rid of all of the
Mercury tubes and go to something that
is safer now they have no way to dispose
of them in lonia because they don't
handle it but as Todd said we're neither
waste any other questions or
comments no all right I um oh okay yeah
go ahead could I just add one little
thing relative to what do you do with
the old paint that people have had in
their basement for hundred
years the people that buy the paint
today if the paint CARE program is in
place will be paying a dollar they will
not be returning all of that paint that
they bought if they buy four gallons
they may be using three of them maybe
three and a half the people that bring
in a can or two of paint that's been in
the basement I think it'll be a
swap because we've been getting that old
paint forever and there is some still
out there that's absolutely true the
amount of oilbased paint that's being
sold currently is greatly reduced
because most companies don't make it
anymore and they can't redo oilbased
paint they can only re do
latex go
ahead just to to follow up on the the
point about um the old paint I don't
believe with a bottle bill in
Massachusetts when you buy a can of beer
it says 5cent deposit on it I don't
believe the paint cans are going to say
$2 or $1 deposit on them so that they're
not if you bring in an old can they're
not going to know the difference between
a new can and an old
can can represent Bixby yeah I have a
question for representative Murray um do
you think that you're going to have this
ready to exact next week I was told to
be ready for the 19th so I'll be ready
yep okay okay because well we have to
have our bills out of committee by the
21st right and um I don't know do you
want us to schedule a work session on
this before we execut so we can explain
the Amendments and I think that makes
sense but I need to uh schedule my next
meeting with some of the stakeholders on
on the issue so
um would it make sense we're meeting
Tuesday and Wednesday of next week or
just just Tuesday
Tuesday so would it we have a nine
o'clock on Tuesday as well
right I I don't do we have a nine
o'clock on Tuesday as well we said the
second oh the second so yes we could
Tuesday the full sub commmittee work
session oh did no I think I think she
was suggesting a a full committee work
session so you can explain to that's
what I was just yeah but we don't have
to do that at nine o'clock we could do
that at 10 o'clock oh I'm sorry 10 and
then you know I can do you want me to
like have like a half hour for that yeah
and then we can go into exec for all the
rest of the bills including this one
yeah okay so why don't we do
that okay for 9 a.m. or excuse me 10 amm
thank
you
okay I mean the the work session the
purpose would be just to basically go
over the entire Amendment yes so that
everybody understands it um we wouldn't
have any time to make any changes to it
but um you know at least everybody will
understand it before we go and vote on
it I think so okay thank you
yeah okay
um well I mean I I think it's a great
idea I think it's a great program it's
just you know ironing out some of the
Kinks of um the workability of it and
um I don't know if if anybody has any
objections
to
this uh proposal I kind of like to know
what they are representative ktoa it's
not an objection it's just a question um
I I still don't understand the logistics
for businesses and
how what kind of system they're going to
have to
implement if any into their Software
System uh to account for
monies and how they're going to make
payment it's going to be an additional
cost to them so I'm just asking the
question just so um and I don't know if
we have any answers for that so I do
know that paint care does provide
guidance to retailers on how to do that
even on the back side of this paper um
there's an organization within paint
care there's a pricing laws like a a
link a a sublink and it offers retailer
information how on how to disclose it to
Consumers how to account for it how to
make sure that they're tracking those
fees um and so I would encourage you to
go to that the pricing laws uh like sub
link or whatever we want to call that
the link through and and see if that
ameliorates any of your concerns and if
it doesn't I'm happy to continue to seek
other answers for you thank you and you
know I I almost think that um some
retailers would be happy to sort of um
offer this new kind of service for their
customers to help them um you know
dispose of any paint that they don't use
right Madam chair I do agree that this
would be a win for retailers that want
to participate in this um and I also
it's kind of like when we came with the
GMO bill right uh everyone wanted us to
put it into law but it really ended up
being a uh a great advertising
tool um for the products that now we see
everywhere non GMO um so I think that
any store or any paint that is you know
advertising that they're participating
in this is a winh so um but I'm just
looking I'm trying to look at all
avenues of it sure and for me as long as
we have the the May provision that they
may participate as opposed to being
compelled to um I think that that's
makes it even more attractive because it
gives it gives the the retailer the
option as to whether or not they want to
participate in it because if they don't
have the room or they don't have the
staff to deal with or whatever you know
that's an
issue yeah represent Bixby and then
confusion yeah so so there are two
aspects of participation one aspect is
the um being a collection site the other
a aspect is uh putting the collecting
the fee right and uh in order for I I
think in order for it to work we're
going to need to have the the fee be a
sh because we don't want to have say
Home Depot say or say no we're not going
to collect the fee uh and then be able
to undercut say your local Sherman
Williams got so uh and then so then
there's the question of okay how much of
a burden is going is the remittance of
the fee going to be on the retailers and
is there any sort of um you know
reimbursement for the cost of doing that
fee remittance and and you know what
what's the what's the what would the
level of that cost be if the fee
remittance is pretty much um just
pushing button then there might not be a
need to uh to do that to to have
a some sort of a payment to the
retailers to do that but if it's going
to cause uh an increased accounting load
then maybe there needs to be some amount
of money that paint care gives to the
retailers who are simply collecting the
fee in order to do the fee process okay
and that might be something that paint
care already has worked out it's
probably something I have worked out
their system because they've done this
in like what a couple dozen other states
already okay yeah um you and then Howard
yeah and and just to piggyback on um
Madam chair what representative Bixby
just said my only you know once the
program is implemented I'm sure the cost
to the retailer is going to be minimal
my concern is The Upfront cost to the
retailer um and what is what is involved
with programming and things so just to
be clear represent Howard I TR thank you
madam chair truthfully mostly most of
what representative Bixby said is what
um is what I wanted to say but I really
do think that if we if we shall if we
put shall in front of collecting the
fees then then we can't say may because
if they're collecting the fees they are
participating in the
plan I will also just say that I think
that um whether or not a to your point
and uh if if a an industry excuse EXC me
a bigger larger retailer is
selling you know 10,000 gallons of paint
a month I don't know and they shall
collect the fee it is already out there
in the waist stream so what do we do
with that and I think to representative
bixby's point is requiring the
collection of the the fee so that when
it comes back to wherever it is to be
recaptured there is an infrastructure in
place to be able to do that and keep it
out of the way streams keep keep it out
of our you know um tonnage in our
landfilling uh hauling fees tipping fees
so that's really why I think the
distinction I don't want to speak for
representative Bixby but that's why I
like the distinction of there being a um
may be a collection site and shall
collect the
fee okay representative
Dy thank you madam chair I think we're
making the assumption that the retail
stores are going to be collecting this
fee and I'm not sure that that's a
correct assumption I think it may be
that the fee is baked in at the
manufacturer site okay so so let's say
um the the can the can of paint costs
the retailer $10 okay and $2 of that $10
is the recycling fee and so it's the
manufacturer who actually makes the
payment to paint care okay and all the
retailer does is put his his or her
markup on it which is what they they do
normally so I mean I think that's an
assumption that we should clarify
because I'm not sure that there's going
to be any additional um burden on the
retailers for collecting any fee at all
I'd like to have that CL get that
clarified representative yeah thank you
madam chair and I understand represent
Dy what you're saying but then the
markup becomes on the total cost of the
paint normally and so technically there
could be an increased fee for uh that
paying a yep your hands up just from my
conversations with Vermont the the when
you buy a gallon of paint at a retailer
it'll show on your receipt $55 per a
gallon $2 whatever it is paint care fee
or whatever they call it but it it
actually shows up on the receipt from
the ret retailer that's the way they do
it in Vermont anyway
okay all right representative Howard
just very quickly I just wonder if this
won't be perceived as a tax in a state
where we resist taxes yeah I can see how
it could very clearly be labeled a fee
but I just hope that it it doesn't have
a bad
perception representative Bixby um I
think that uh there are people who would
probably choose to label it that way we
had our dog license is labeled as a tax
just last week uh so I but I don't think
that but I think that in terms of is
this something we should go forward with
with because it's a very sensible way of
dealing with a problem that is currently
causing
our uh municipalities to face uh more
taxes that go that more costs that go
onto our property tax um I think that
you're doing that that it's a user fee
that is appropriately
distributed
100% I agree 100% I just mentioned that
out of an abundance of caution
representative
kraton it's it's a fair um concern
representative Howard I I just uh had a
bill go on unanimous consent that added
a $3 fee to boat registration and the
the reason that it was to pay for the
actual sticker and so and so it was a it
it was it was considered a fee to pay
for an item that you put on your boat
and so I think if this is couched in the
terms of this is a fee to get rid of the
remainder of the paint that you just
bought and the cost to the the cost to
the town of doing that is not absorbed
by taxpayer but by the user then to me
that that's a reasonable explanation I
again you never know how people are
going to take it but that's the way I
look at it and I also think if I may
Madam sure good that it also provides
yet another uh opportunity for these
products to not just simply be
recaptured but then potentially resold
into more affordable paint products that
folks of all economic diversity can you
know I was just looking at the cost that
some of these gallons of paint are
$75 so when you're looking at this type
of model these are being sold at a
fraction of that for repurposed uh
paints so
yeah okay I think we've uh pretty much
exhausted all the con conversation and
I'm I'm glad that we've you know talked
about a bunch of these things um and so
we'll break for lunch and be back here
all
e
for
who is representative
Bailey may he may not even be here to
introduce theill so it might be a real
quick
hearing
Jesus I need
greedy
thank you I appreciate you doing that so
is everybody here who's gonna be here
for this
afternoon Davis is coming back Davis we
can't we can get
need
okay yeah y yep
yep
okay of what okay I'm going to get
started with um the hearing for or HB
1575 prohibiting the state of New
Hampshire from enforcing any federal
agricultural checkoff
program and uh as I look around the room
I do not see the sponsor of the bill the
sole sponsor of the bill representative
Bailey here to introduce the bill so I
guess all I'm going to say is that um
this bill prohibits the state of New
Hampshire from en forcing payments for
any federal check off program for a
agricultural
Commodities and so what it does is uh
apparently it
repeals renumbers a section in 425 colon
2 it adds uh some sections
regarding um the federal check off
program
fees and
adds a bunch of other stuff so I don't
really that's all I know about this bill
um
so there is a pink card we do have a
pink card coming more pink cards coming
but the first person to come and speak
to oppose this bill is Robert Johnson
from the Farm
Bureau welcome to environment and
agriculture come and tell us why this
bill should not be
passed thank thank you madam chair
members of the committee for the record
Rob Johnson representing the New
Hampshire Farm the federation's policy
director and we do oppose uh House Bill
1575 we're not clear really what the
intent is uh the the the department and
the commissioner will be testifying uh
as you keep getting this card now there
um they they they do provide office
space to Grant a state Dairy promotion
which receives check off funds uh what's
that strike
that okay they did they did they no
longer okay so I'm not so again it makes
it even more unclear as to what the what
the bill does but so you know there the
there are I believe it is 21 20 2122
Federal check off programs for various
Commodities the ones that are farmers
participate in New Hampshire at least
primarily that I'm aware of would be
Dairy there there's also a beef check
off there's a Christmas tree check off
and I'm probably missing a couple of
others but there's all kinds of them uh
Across the Nation and these are
voluntary programs uh uh that I should
say they're they're programs that have
been adopted by a majority of of uh
participating commodity groups and and
um like for the for example the dairy
check off uh it's 15 cents of every 100
weight of milk sold goes to the check
off and Farmers have an opportunity that
so much of it goes to the the federal
check off uh program and then they can
allocate a certain amount of that money
and is it five or 10 cents
five yeah five to five to Federal then
out of the 10 cents they can they can
allocate locally and in and again
correct me if I'm wrong gentleman back
there but there's some Dairy Farmers
back here uh who and that 10 cents uh
they can allocate that to the Granite
State Dairy promotion which is inhouse
and prior to recently had an office at
the Department of Agriculture and there
also is a New England Dairy organization
that some choose to to send there either
five or 10 cents to to and then what
they do is they you've seen the gut
milk advertis on that that's Dairy
promotion money you've seen the beef
check off money that that is you know
that is uh uh used for for National
advertising I believe they Christmas
trees I think it's the same thing I
think it's 15 cents of every either it's
every tree or every dollar to be honest
I don't know but again these programs
have been approved by a majority of the
the producers and they're they're
popular and well-received and I guess we
again we we're opposed we're not really
understanding what what the bill does or
why it's being introduced so why do they
call it a check off program what it
what's I that sort of throws me off
is oh yeah you
you dollar Che an S for for for beef
when you sell when you sell uh animals
for beef yeah there's $1 do that is
supposed to go to the into the the
program okay
and it's something I can say in in in uh
as far as the the enforcement of it it's
from what I've seen it's it's virtually
non-existent at least in this part of
the
country well well I'm saying for for
beef for for the for beef I'm sorry for
beef yeah so do you know if there
are Dairy Farmers or whatever other
producers that are involved in these
check off
programs
that
um would prefer not
to you know give their money I'm sure
there are some but it uh it's a I would
say a vast minority I mean that there
has been a number of court cases over
the years uh saying that it is a a
violation of their first amendment
speech rights um but it it is nothing
that I'm aware some at some levels of
Court levels that those those uh cases
have been successful but on appeal they
have not been because I see what this
Bill is saying is that you know
agricultural producers in the state
shall retain the right to choose whether
to participate in state level check off
programs and shall not be subject to any
form of coercion penalty or legal action
for opting out of such programs so I
guess that's what the the author the
sponsor of this bill is is speaking to
is the fact that there are people who
are compelled to write this check for
whatever transaction uh against their
will so to speak if there are any in New
Hampshire that are vehemently opposed
they certainly haven't been in touch
with me
okay all right any other questions from
the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you I hope that's helpful I was not
prepared to speak today thank you
appreciate it um so I will now call uh
commissioner Shan asper from Department
of Agriculture to speak on HB
1575 and he opposes this bill as well I
do Madame chair thank you members of the
committee I am Shan Jasper commissioner
of the Department of Agriculture markets
and food I will tell you that I made um
numerous attempts to contact the sponsor
to have a conversation but he uh
declined to respond to any of my
attempts to communicate with him um so I
don't have the benefit of knowing what
he was thinking of but um first of all
there seems to be two different things
he's talking about here one is the
federal check off program which there
are dozens several dozen um of and then
it's talking about state check off
programs which we don't have any so
first of all I would tell you that in
order for the Department to ever enforce
the federal check off program three
things would have to happen one there
would have to be legislation at the
federal level asking the states to
participate in enforcing it two the
state legislature would have to give a
directive to the Department of
Agriculture to help enforce the programs
and three you would have to mandate that
there be a Statewide registry of animals
in in sales so that I would
know what um commodity were being sold
so that I could help enforce that so
none of those things are likely to
happen but certainly all three are
certainly not going to happen I'm sure
the the latter of the two would not
happen in in the state of New Hampshire
and I would certainly oppose that these
are federal programs so don't confuse
you
know the the issue of state and federal
because the second page talks about a
state program which doesn't
exist um so yeah people might not want
to participate in that which doesn't
exist and I would not encourage that
either um but this bill is wholly
unnecessary because there are no current
mechanisms in place for the Department
of Agriculture to
enforce um this so we're
asking the bill asks us to do something
that can't be done say don't do what you
can't do okay okay any glad to answer
any questions any questions
um okay so there there are no State
checkoff
programs and um the federal programs we
really can't do we don't have any
control over
anyway
okay yeah it would take a it would take
some sort of a Cooperative agreement but
I would the department would need
authoriz authorization from the state to
do that to begin
with okay representative ktoa thank you
madam chair and thank you commissioner
for being here can you speak to us a
little bit about the granted State Dairy
promotion program and how that works
sure um to a to a small degree and I
know you do have some testimony from Amy
Hall the executive director so the
federal check off level uh as you've
heard there are there's money that goes
to to the federal program 5 cents 100
weight I believe and then 10 cents which
farmers can direct that 10 cents to
wherever they want um and I don't know
if this is still going on but for a
while there was a Florida farmer who
liked what we were doing in New
Hampshire and he was directing his check
off money his his uh 10 cents or at
least a portion of that to come to New
Hampshire to support our program so
that's they get to decide so there are
two really that
cover um New Hampshire one is Granite
State Dairy and the other is a more
Regional one I can't recall the name of
it not involved in that um but so some
producers do have or did have their
money going to the the regional program
where most have their money going to
Grand estate Dairy
promotion okay any other questions from
the
committee oh and and if I could I would
say that is the one that is easy to be
um uh funded because that those go
through the uh through the milk co-ops
so that money is taken out at that level
and sent from the co-ops to where it's
being directed so with beef it would be
the individual with pork it would be the
individuals other Commodities would be
the responsibility of the individuals I
I and that would really from what I know
is truly uh voluntary because I don't
think the feds have any idea who's
producing what you know out in the mid
West where you're producing you know
thousands of animals it's pretty easy to
to get to that and determine but in New
Hampshire I have not heard of any any
problems at all or complaints okay all
right well thank you very much
Robertson
uh hi I'm Jamie Robertson and uh my
family owns uh Bohanan Farm over in
Hopkinton New Hampshire and we're also k
creery
um I think the commissioner sum things
up pretty well and Rob before that but
if you had any any uh questions for a
Dairy Farmer themselves I am one of
those um the the one thing I would say
is that we are independent from a co-op
because we process all of our own milk
and the commissioner is right that the
co-ops take care of if you ship your
milk to either like the hood plant or
agramar for cabbat cheese stuff like
that that's all handled on the by the
co-op offices and gets deducted out of
the milk check that we get sent back to
Dairy Farmers um we're a little
different because we process all our own
milk so we have to keep track of that
and we have to report how much milk we
process to the federal Market
administrator in Boston and then they
report that to the National milk
promotion folks in Chicago and we get a
bill from Chicago to pay 15 cents for
every 100 pounds of milk we sell that's
how that's how milk's always classified
as 100 pounds but and then you can
choose five five cents has to go to the
National and then you can choose for 10
cents either to go to Granite State
Dairy promotion which is still a federal
program but it's it's a regional federal
program just for New Hampshire run by
New Hampshire Dairy Farmers and then the
other oh you can either send your 10
cents there or you can send your 10
cents to the uh New England Dairy
promotion which is not every state has a
Granite State Dairy promotion um not
every state has their own private Dairy
promotion arm of the federal program um
and so that covers all of New England
and you have your choice of where that
10 cents goes um and as far as the beef
check off we do get um most of us Dairy
Farmers we sell our our C cows we call
them when they're done milking go to a
sail Barn um and there is a beef check
off is done at the sale barn and
deducted from our check before we get
our check back from the sailb barn there
okay so my question to you is what is it
so what is this total what is the this
amount to say on a monthly basis or a
yearly basis what how much do you have
to deduct off your
product it ends up being a
fairly let me pull out my calculator
here
sorry
where so for us it's um we're shipping
about a quarter of a million pounds of
milk a month which is fairly small for
New Hampshire not tiny by any means but
um and that's just under $400 a month
okay I mean it's
not um we spend a lot more ourselves now
marketing our own brand um but that's
you know and this is separate from it's
not marketing like Hood milk or um I I
don't not that goes back 40 years hood
or um you know it doesn't Market name
brand milk it just markets milk as a
whole and it also does a lot of research
for new products and things like that
also and so and for that
$400 what do you feel that you get back
in return I'm one who believes in the
program I believe that that that we
aren't paying enough in advertising
personally but I I don't know that I'm
uh I guess I wouldn't say that that's
probably the common thought of folks um
but I think that uh if you look at what
other beverage Industries put in into
advertising I think 15 cents 100 weight
is is a pretty nominal amount of money
to invest in in advertising in new
product
development okay and so for the beef end
what what kinds of services do they
provide for you for that uh same uh beef
what's for dinner okay that that kind of
um James Garner used to do their ads you
know so that that's
um yeah and same thing I think that
Megan uh I'm sorry representative Murray
okay God no it's all right thanks Madam
chair um so I I I did have a question
and I can't remember and maybe this is a
question for commissioner Jasper if I
remember are value added products
included in the 10 cents or is it just
liquid so it's it's just
on
the well raw milk that goes from it it's
on it's on the farmer side of things we
have the check off that's just at farm
farm gate I would say
um I guess probably I don't know of any
um cut off where if you ship under x
amount you're not charged um I think
probably like the commissioner said
there isn't a tremendous amount of
oversight on people that aren't um we
big enough so that the federal Market
administrator follows us um and wants to
know how much milk we sell um so I guess
if if you had a couple of cows maybe
you're supposed to pay for it but but
probably no one's checking up on you
right any other questions represented
Duty thank you madam chair are uh is
your brand name kukut Kuka creary yes
KET crey okay so I just want to put in a
plug when you go to your store because I
always try to buy KET creary but it's
not always
available um but I really think I
noticed the difference so and and and
just the fact that we can support a farm
you know that we know all the milk is
coming from New Hampshire is really
exciting but I will ask you why do you
not have 2% milk I haven't seen it in
the store you're right um we have we
have uh low fat which is kind of 1% um
and and that's a blue label so we do
have a low fat but it might not be at
your store
um mainly uh the milk consumption has
changed drastically in the last 15 years
and um and there isn't a huge market for
the lower fat milks that's um
unfortunately a lot of that is switched
over to um
melt non-melt
milks all right non milk beverages I
call them something but it's not
appropriate
[Laughter]
here okay any other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for coming today today and for uh
answering our questions thank you all
right great uh representative Bixby um
would it make sense to exact this right
to do we have a do we have a here five n
you don't well Jim represent is here I
didn't see him sorry so three four he
was over there four five six seven
okay let's do it okay we'll do it
we get it
done oh I'm gonna uh first I have to
close out the hearing so I'm going to
close out the hearing for HB
1575 uh we have uh on our blue sheet
four people against this bill and four
against um online we had uh three in
neutral yes ma'am uh we just don't have
a quum right now so we need to wait yeah
how did you Jim just W out yes he
did so we will wait for a
second oh now we have a quorum now we
quorum what my Green Sheet your green
sheet oh
okay all right um so I I guess we have
decided to exec this bill now we have
some time actually and I will open up
the exec session for HB
1575 uh prohibiting the state of New
Hampshire from enforcing any federal
agricultural check off program do I hear
a motion does anyone want practice
writing a blur I got
two
it represent CLK oh but oh go ahead oh
you're on you're good go ahead
representative smart you can do it good
moveed so what do I do me I make a
motion to to what it itl this bill okay
I'm represent Duty seconds I second it
and representative smart might you want
to speak to your motion I do yeah just
say um why why this bill should be ited
I don't really completely understand
this
bill I guess it should be it because
they all wanted itl how's that good
reason that's a good enough reason any
discussion representative Bixby well I
think that uh we have a couple of a
couple of clear no clear indicators one
one is is and you might want to be
taking notes because you're going to be
writing the report on
this so uh one issue was that the uh
Prime sponsor did not show up to explain
it to
us and the reason for the bill was not
clear and
the uh second reason is that the
commissioner let us know that the
department currently has the state has
currently has no power to enforce
anything about the check off program at
the federal level and there is no check
off program at the state level so it's
pointless representative kamwa thank you
madam chair and they have really good
milk representative kraton and the other
the other thing that I would add was
that the Farm Bureau came out against it
as
well okay there's any other discussion
on this bill um then I would ask the
clerk to call the role please thank you
madam chair the motion is itl and hb1
1575 representative kraton I
representative coma
yes hold on representative
smart uh
Mike yes thank you represent Bixby yes
represent sakas
yes thank you represent dsy yes
represent Murray yes represent Jama yes
representative H Haskins I uh Madame
chair
yes motion is 110 shall I put it on
consent please
do okay I'm going to close out the exact
1575 and I just wanted down here smart
Duty
okay now now comes the fun
part I get to I get to vacate here for a
bill and I will turn over the mic to my
esteemed colleague representative
kraton
and I'd like to open a hearing on HB
1698 and I call Representative Aaron to
introduce the
bill I would be delighted to introduce
this bill to you
so this
bill is intended
to
allow the farmers in our state who have
certification um to spray their
crops
using drones currently in our state
statute all we are allowed to spray
aerially is from helicopters and
airplanes and it makes a lot of sense to
allow our Farmers to spray their crops
using drones because number one they
would be could be spot spraying and not
have to blanket spray an entire acreage
acreage of
property um it would uh be more
economical for the farmers uh because
they're not using as much product to be
spraying it's more
environmentally um prudent because again
they're not using as much product and
they are
using you know it's it's
targeted um application of pesticide or
herb aside and
um so this this would only allow um for
agricultural purposes we wouldn't be
using it for you know golf courses or
any of that kind of thing and uh so this
just adds a section to the uh current
law at RSA 430 colon 34 hyphen a section
4 um which adds in and so I have also
brought an amendment with uh me today
it's uh 202 24-10
182h which changes the initial language
to say that um the uh unmanned
aircraft would uh spray at a height not
exceeding 20 feet above ground level as
opposed to 50 feet and after being on a
phone call and talking to several people
about it uh it was felt that the 20 foot
uh ground level was more appropriate
that anything above that is actually
when the Drone would be fing around and
not spraying anything and also by
limiting it to a 20 foot level you are
not getting into the situation where
there'd be any drift of pesticide to
other properties neighboring
properties and that's pretty much um all
that I have about this bill um we do use
the RSA 22 colon 3 uh Roman numeral
27-a uh which is what defines what an
unmanned aircraft is in um in our
statutes and um um think I have that
somewhere
here uh yeah I do which is um small
unman aircraft means an unman aircraft
as defined in Federal Regulations so um
if you look on Federal
Regulations um it dep it uh 14 CFR part
107 uh in federal law also defines what
small unmanned aircraft systems are and
uh I think I sent a link to the
committee uh with all those definitions
included so that's what this bill does
it basically gives our Farmers a new
improved tool in um in being able to
manage the pests on their in their
crops and I'd be happy to take some
questions and representative Bixby yeah
so
um in the Federal Regulations uh regard
related to the unmanned aircraft uh do
the federal federal reg regulations
require licensing for operating those
yes okay thank
you and representative
Murray thank you Mr chair that was
really my point was just to make sure
that um there are federal requirements
and they also have um certain
requirements to transmit like when
they're flying them so that's all part
of like the notice to the FAA um and I
I'm assuming that those things would
fall under all of the uh uh 107 107 is
pretty comprehensive they go they it
goes for uh several Pages talking about
um certification procedures it has
definitions um inspection testing and
demonstration of compliance safety event
reporting uh a whole lot of things so
it's pretty comprehensive the federal uh
federal law um and I would also say that
um you know for for a farmer May who has
pesticide
certification
um they may employ a contractor to do
the work for them as well and the
contractor who has the drones who were
doing the spraying um would have all the
necessary certifications that they need
to fly their
drones and repres representative ger
thank you Mr chair thank you represented
for taking my question this may be one
of those kind of like differences
without a real distinction or
distinction without a difference you in
your testimony referred to pesticides
but then you also added herbicides and
I'm wondering the language of the bill
is specific to pesticides does it matter
well I did talk to um Mr rouso who is
chair of the pesticide control board and
the definition of pesticides includes
herbicides thank you for that
clarification representative com
[Laughter]
oops thank you Mr chair and Madame chair
thank you Representative no I was just
going to clarify that pesticides is the
overall language used to include uh you
know herbicides insecticides
Etc thank you are there any further
questions for Madam
chair habits are hard to
break yeah so
um how does this might be do we have we
might have someone coming up who can ex
go into this more deeply but um how does
uh the spraying of uh pesticides at 20
ft or below compared with compare with
the procedure for doing it uh from a
plane at a higher level or versus um
using a ground spraying rig uh which
which is it more similar to this is more
similar to a ground spraying rig okay in
terms of um well if you're if you're
going to spray
aerially um with an airplane or
helicopter there is an a whole section
of notification for a Butters or for you
know people who are around the area
being sprayed um there there's some
notification procedures that go along
with that and um for for ground spraying
we don't have any um notification
procedures which would be the same for
the Drone activity okay thank you and
representative Murray uh thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
I representative I have a
um I I just want to make sure the same
sort of application control standards
and regulations that would apply for
ground application or any of those other
things would still exist right in the
same framework it would just sort of all
come underneath of yes okay as as I
yes repr
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um would you say that um when we we're
thinking about spraying a drone at 20
feet uh we're spraying down where with
an aerial spray and an orchard we're
spraying up so that's probably going
could even go higher than 20 feet would
you say that um would is a reasonable
assumption I don't know I would uh ask
that of uh anybody who would be coming
after me who's aarm mer who is doing the
spraying
sure okay seeing no further questions
thank you ma'am appreciate your
testimony at this time I'd like to call
uh commissioner Jasper
please
Johnson yes sir you may yes some things
that I may want to support in my okay
good and may we call Mr Robert Johnson
of the Farm Bureau
thank you Mr chair I I have some
handouts may I get those out before I
speak yes
please
and
yeah Madam chair if you if you could
fill out a pin
card sir welcome to the committee
welcome back to the committee this
afternoon thank thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee again for the
record Rob Johnson representing the New
Hampshire Farm Bureau as a federation's
policy director and if you'll forgive me
I'm going to I'm going to um read much
of what I'm handing out of my letter so
that I can stay on point and I'll just
add uh to that as I as I go what what I
have provided you is our letter of
support and then a attached to that and
I'll speak to it later but it's a
section 44807 of the FFA uh regulations
and then also the the uh part um uh p506
which is the rule uh that uh goes along
with the statute and then in the letter
what I've provided is in the box at the
last half of the the letter is the
existing RSA and if you flip the page I
incorporate the amendment that's
introduced as introduced by the chair
with and read the the the uh additional
Amendment
there Farm Bureau is in in strong
support of of House Bill 1698 it it's
it's a bill that we have been working
with the sponsor on and and uh uh uh
based on uh requests from our membership
have have have worked with her on you
you'll hear from from uh the uh at least
the the member who initially members who
initially approached us and what it what
the bill does in a nutshell it provides
licensed pesticide applicators holding a
Federal Aviation Administration part 107
certification which which was required
to fly an unmanned aircraft uh or drone
uh the uh practical and I'm I'm
underlying practical option uh to use
the technology uh to to protect uh to
apply to as a crop to apply crop
protectant and I say practical because
technically you currently can use a
drone but the rule is is prohibitive you
this it makes no sense uh the the and
I'll get into that a little bit but just
currently if I want to apply pesticides
via aerial application that includes a
drone helicopter airplane I have to get
the the application to the division for
one thing 90 days before which which in
an application for a farmer makes no
sense and then there's other public
notification requirements and and we'll
get into that so again it's a this is to
provide a practical option um the the
sponsor touched on the the
um the the amendment and if you see the
bill is introduced had a a limit of 50
feet and we we're we're uh supporting a
reduction in 20 ft to that and initially
and speaking with drone applicators the
question we had was well how much how
much height do you need and what the
answer initially was well we need 50 fet
well they need the 50 feet in order to
get the payload to where it needs to be
most applications are under 20 feet
nearly all of them are under 10 feet but
they they we asking for the 20 to give
that that little bit of that buffer but
again that just so you know that that
initial 50 was really about the height
that a a a a drone would be with its
payload so that that's why we're
requesting that that
and there has is existing under the
existing statute which was adopted 1995
there's never been an agricultural
approval for the reasons I've stated
it's just it's it's part of it's the we
didn't have the technology that we do
now but also just the the the the uh
burden of it
all the bill amends RSA 430 col 34- a
which again I said earlier pass into law
1995 with with airplanes and helicopters
in
mind the RSA and the accompanying rules
which are was PES 506 aerial application
of pesticides I have provided you are
overly burdensome costly and not
practical for targeted drone application
of crop protectants it includes
requiring a a a a detailed map of the
treatment area
identifying sensitive areas which which
are really not defined in the rule but
it it's there are uh within there's two
stages there's a a uh uh the the uh um
the use in a in what are considered
non-residential areas and then in
residential areas if it's considered a
residential area which is very broadly
drawn basically anything zoned in the
community is residential requires the
the uh the enhanced uh permit uh if
uh which would then require with that
enhanced piece then it's it's you know
notifications butter
notifications uh Noti in newspapers
um I'm trying to decide which order I
want to go in here um in and and I we
were hoping to have a a uh a a
applicator here today A J applicator
from mod of state who's who's doing it
in New York and Pennsylvania uh he was
unfortunately this morning was on Route
and he got a call that one of his
children were sick and he had to turn
back so at some point hopefully we can
make him available if the committee has
questions but he did raise a concern to
me in in further reading the bill with
the with the with the proposed language
in in Roman 4 there's the term being
used in that last complete sentence
unmanned
aircraft and and then it cites RSA 422
colon 3 uh with the Roman numeral well e
you know I'm not going to it's What what
27 um that Roman 27 if you if you look
at the statute the definition of small
unmanned aircraft means an unmanned
aircraft is defined in Federal Federal
Regulations as amended and I provided
that definition below which I believe
the sponsor has provided you the more
complete statue which which which limits
uh the these drone uses to 55 pounds and
he said that's that is basically would
make the the statute uh close to useless
you certainly wouldn't draw people from
out state to for our Farmers to hire
because of that limit you got to
remember that five gallons of water
alone weighs 40 pounds so it's it's just
too small so he he alerted me to this I
cited up a and bold that section
44807 which if if uh we we in order to
make this useful we we need to be made
clear in the statute you could read the
statute as still allowing it but it's
not very clear and that would that would
make it make it clear and what that
section 44807 is as he termed it to me
it's it's it's it's termed experimental
section by the FFA but it's what he uses
to apply in in other states and as he
has telling told me that uh this aerial
application is essentially allowed in
every state in the Union except for the
New England states so we we're a little
behind the curve and our farmers do not
have uh use of the technology that many
others
do the as the the sponsor did site the
Drone application offers Farmers a
number of benefits related to efficiency
in safety and I've listed some of these
it's really this the timeliness is huge
the targeted application as as some
Growers have said to me they they turn
with Precision they they really get are
able to apply that product where where
it's needed in in in some some of the
areas where our our farmers and I think
some of them will speak to this but in
corn it's currently a a I'll call it
weed bur cucumber that is a it's a Vine
and and it it it's it's uh it literally
will will um uh uh uh when when you use
it it'll it'll uh what do I want to say
stop a combine it's that it'll it'll
tangle in and literally bring it to a
hall it's that it's that aggressive in
and strong of a of a weed um other areas
would be our Fruit Growers they
currently use blast sprayers in order to
get up into the canopy of the tree and
that said the Drone would would offer
much more Precision um also mentioned to
me has been when you get into small
fruit crops like blueberries raspberries
that type of thing often there'll be uh
limited uh uh rows that have access to
the to the through the the planting and
and a a smaller drone at a at a small
height would allow them to to apply
protectants especially you've you
probably heard of spoted wing jopa
that's a big problem now that will will
land on fruit just before it's ripe or
as it's ripening lay aegs and then the
the the the the food is gone so that
would be a a value there um but in in
addition to uh you know with with soil I
mean if if you if you have a problem now
and you've got wet soil and you need to
get on it with a with a with a with a
vehicle of some type you know you're
risking soil compaction which damages
the roots of the of the uh of your
growing crop and then there's you know
the fuel and Time Savings and and I I
think probably one of the the the the
other real benefits of this is worker
protection because the the product is
being applied away from I mean there's
also obviously where the work the drones
are being filled but there's you know
then the product is being dispersed away
from people so there's a we we we see
that as a a real
benefit so I'll I'll try I'll sum it up
here that you know we we we we urge you
the committee to to find a way to enable
uh the the the the use of drones to
apply crop protectants it's it's it is
it's the it is the latest in technology
it puts our our farmers at the The
Cutting Edge and and like I said it's
from what I'm being told is pretty much
every state outside of New England
allows it I know I was told that you
Rhode Island does because they don't
have an aerial application statute like
we do I guess this aerial application
piece is more to the in Northern New
England and we do see it as a true
benefit for Farmers as well as the
environment and and um I I'll leave it
at that you've got some some experts
here that will offer you some some I
think a very informative testimony thank
you oh thank thank you very much for
your testimony the the one question I've
got is so 55 PBS wasn't the right number
did they offer a number that
that my understanding is and I I I I
just learned this recently so I had to
do some quick research but this what I
attached to you that section
44807 is is is what needs to be enabled
by by the the language that's what
that's what this particular operator
operates under and what he told me
that's what others operate right under
so I'll like I'll I will work to get the
committee some language um as to what
would Encompass that okay any questions
representative muray uh thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
um so I I did have a couple of of
questions there are you aware that there
is there is an exemption permit that is
available through and is required
through the FAA for drones weighing over
55 pounds so there is already that
there's already a requirement for an
exemption permit for Farmers to use
under a agricultural use with preference
given to um those who are seeking the
exemption under agricultural related
operations and then my second
followup if I may is uh with regard
to this specific Bill
are are we talking about the launch of a
drone on the footprint of an of a
property not traversing somebody else's
property where a butter notification or
anything like that would have to happen
we we're talking the launching on the
site of the application okay thank you
and in in in in U clarification to I
guess your first question my
understanding is that this what I'm
talking about this which is attach this
uh section
44807 is something that is under the
part 107 The Lure and then this is this
is part of that why I bring it up is
this drone applicator who does this in
other states and further looking uh what
I did is I sent him the complete statute
and then I also I I sent him the
definition of of
4223 and that's when he came back and he
said it just wasn't clear to him that
what was needed and there might be
because there's also a there's a
definition of uh small unmanned aircraft
and there's a
unmanned
aircraft I'm gonna figet this with
another word that he just said it just
wasn't clear to him and that maybe we
need to be looking at that that's why
I'm raising it now so it doesn't come be
become an issue later okay um yes one
please I'm wondering if it makes sense
to then just refer back to some of the
language that's already enumerated under
I think it's 14 CFR part 91 which is a
round drone application through the FAA
and that's why I'm wondering if there
might be a more appropriate word it it
could be part of my hesitancy also is I
should mention that this draft language
is I worked with director Russo
initially to put this together and and
he's currently not available so so
that's why um there's a reason he cited
that I I guess we need to find out
exactly why if there's a reason or
whatever fair enough represent
Bigby yeah so I was just
um just wanted to let you know that
we're going to be exact backing this on
Tuesday so uh so there's going to be a
relatively short turnaround time for any
Amendment and it sounds like we're going
to need to have to amend it in order to
get the appropriate uh aircraft size
language um added to it uh so uh would
you be able to work with the chair uh to
help get her that language um
expeditiously yeah I my we probably will
need language but I'm going to say I'm
not I'm not sure and and just your
question brings up another one that the
chair asked earlier relative to the size
I I did asked the the Drone operator
that I've been working with about what
he was talking about for size under his
you know this the section 44 and and he
says well he says mine are upwards of
400 pounds that help
you yeah any help you could give us with
that and you we want to write it so that
it's accurate and helpful and if it's 55
lbs it needs to be 400b then we're not
doing that so anything you could do be
would be great thank you thank you and
cleanup thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee I am still the
Commissioner of
Agriculture um and you know I'll support
uh what the executive director just had
to say I mean uh in support of the bill
with the amendment of 20 feet I think
that it is much more environmentally
friendly although currently we don't
have to the best of my knowledge anyone
licensed to spray with helicopters or
planes and have probably not had anyone
for decades doing that so it is spraying
from the ground which uh question
earlier was about how high that would
have to go I don't know for sure but I
would certainly say when you're spraying
anything up it's going to probably have
to go higher because it's going to be
trying to reach into the the field and
that's going to uh lend to more drift
than something that is going down and
obviously they're going to be uh
spraying in in any time they're spraying
their spray when there is you know as
little wind as possible but I think this
really is the most environmentally
friendly way to do this and obviously 50
50 pounds is not enough to make this
practicable uh and so I hope that uh the
chair and the executive director find a
solution to this because I think it is
something that is is very much needed in
for agriculture in New Hampshire okay
thank you any questions for the
commissioner see no questions thank you
sir appreciate your
testimony and next I'd like to call Tom
Buro
bury
good afternoon I'm G to apologize I woke
up horse this morning um Tom bodry
Walpole New Hampshire I'm an independent
certified crop adviser I work with
primarily dairy farms in New Hampshire
Vermont and
Massachusetts I'm one of the people who
I don't know it's the end of August
beginning of September we started
pushing so we could determine what we
needed to do to allow the use of
drones where I see it being used with
respect to dairy farms Rob Johnson
mentioned bur cucumber bur cucumber is a
weed that germinates late June July so
the pre-emergent herbicides have lost
their res residual effect by that time
buru cber will climb up and canopy out
over the top of
cornfields right now it's sprayed with
what we call a self-propelled sprayer um
it's operated on the ground somebody
goes in and corn will often be 10 to 12
feet high so it's very high the
clearance on the sprayer underneath the
sprayer itself is maybe four 4 and 1/2
ft underneath the booms it can get up to
10 or 11 feet but going in with the
sprayer you are running some corn over
so you are damaging the crop also you
cannot see the specific areas of the
field that has bur cucumber in it so
typically the whole field is being
sprayed if it's a 30 acre field you go
in and you spray the Whole 30 Acres um
using a drone they can determine where
the cucumber is that needs to be sprayed
and go in and do spot spraying so it
will result in less pesticides being
used so that's very environmentally
friendly um and I realize there's
probably some concerns with
neonicotinoids okay I believe the
beekeepers are
concerned so neonix in forage production
such as corn silage is basically put on
the corn seed when it's before its
planted it's a dry powder that goes
on the chemicals are herbicides that are
used to take care of the bur cucumber do
not have any neon in them so that the
the concern for neonix being aily
concern are there any
questions repres Jal thank you Mr chair
it's good to see you again yeah uh
so I really appreciate the the
discussion about uh the neonix because
that was yes we have been hearing from
beekeeper so that definitely uh
clarifies that I appreciate that I just
had a question about something you said
which does strike me as a really great
point about being able to identify
specific areas right and so would that
be kind of a a just trying to imagine
the process would it be kind of a
two-stage process in the sense that
there would be a preliminary kind of
survey with the Drone U I'm just trying
to imagine how find those specific
places it sounds like the Dr do have
cameras on them so you could go up and
determine where it is and I expect when
he's in transport from spraying one area
to spraying another if he goes up to 50
feet he will be able to see that and go
right to that area may I follow and I'm
just so would that would happen during
the spraying or would there okay and and
typically so I'm scouting fields for I
work with about 25,000 acres and I Scout
fields
July and August and we really don't
start seeing the Cucumber until August
when it comes up in canopies so we
identify there's cucumber there we
identify it really needs to be taken
care of because um in some instances
it'll canopy over the corn and actually
start pulling the corn down okay um and
then from there the Drone operator would
identify the areas of the field that
really needed to be sprayed if you were
in a self-propelled sprayer the operator
is sitting there about 12 feet in the
air but when you're in 12 to 10 foot
tall corn all you're seeing is the top
of the Corn so okay thank you very much
was that muray thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question um not um is
it true that not all drones have
cameras that is true but this would be a
commercial operator that would come in
to do it okay and even um if a Dairy
Farmer were to get their own drone they
would get a camera so they could see it
would be useless to go up without having
a
camera follow up yes ma'am so would it
make sense for there to be a requirement
however though for there to be usage of
a drone with camera capability to avoid
the potential of indiscriminate
application
um I guess I wouldn't see that as
necessary because the Drone operator the
only way he is operating that drone is
with a camera to know where he is in the
works okay any further
questions thank you sir for your
testimony I appreciate it thank
you I'd like to call Mr Tom saer
please
hi my name's Tom Sawyer I'm a Dairy
Farmer from walpool New Hampshire we put
in about 250 acres of corn silage and I
was one of the ones that was had a
problem last year in August I looked
into this you know trying to get a drone
person from New York to come and spray
my Fields because it was August and and
uh he was more than willing to come and
he was we went back and forth for about
a week and he said we just can't do it
because of the pesticide rules and and
that so that's um the big things that
you
know we we went in and sprayed it with a
land you know drove over a lot of corn
and it was better than not spraying it
but we lost a you know on the acreage
that we had to
respray we lost a lot of corn and
so we were just hoping to get this you
know so we could do it this year if if
we need
to um I talked with him some and
hopefully it'll come to get it through
and get this
done and uh I'm sorry are are you okay
so and this bill meets the requirements
um that would allow you to do that if
this bill passed would you be allowed to
do that as you planned that's what I was
hop hoping but now they brought up a
couple other things that hopefully we
can get worked out but that
was yes that's that's what okay the gist
of it was cool
it's and there there are some different
ways you know like this spot spraying
there's also some other you know like
they come in um the person that I was
working with he had uh can't remember
how many drones he has but it's like
three or four drones and he you know
like he sends one up and starts spraying
and sends another one up and it's
computerized M you know mapped out he
can do it different ways with maps um so
it's not
like if he's doing a you know like a
certain field of that square right there
it would be computerized and the drones
would just spray it and then come
home the side of the field whatever but
and then if your spa
a you can get up there and see where you
need to spray and go to that spot and
spray
it fairly accurate Fair reliable would
you say very accurate from what I've
read I've never done it
and as Tom bodri said I I don't believe
that you'll see Farmers themselves doing
it because you've got to get licensed to
fly the Drone and pesticide application
and a lot of farms have gone to hiring
it done just because it's probably
probably safer they know the rules
better and but I know they can like
directionally spray so if they're going
along instead of just spraying straight
down they may tilt a little bit the the
nozzles and stuff like that so it's I
think from what everything I've been
told it's very little drift
and that's what we're shooting for oh
thank you any represent big yes thank
you for taking my question um
so one of the issues with drift is that
if you are um spraying in high wind
conditions then drift is much more
likely uh would it be the case that if
you're flying a drone if you were using
a drone you you wouldn't be able to fly
the Drone in the conditions that would
be problematic for drift correct okay
thank you they're more worry more about
drift just because the drones the drones
are very expensive ensive and so you
know you don't want to go up with them
windy all right seeing no further
questions I'd like to call thank you sir
for your testimony we appreciate it and
uh Jamie Jamie
Robertson my son showed up and I will uh
defer to my son I think he put in a card
also um because he's the one who
has and so you're sigh yes cool so you
want me to D destroy
this they're all over it he just saved
us five minutes s I'd like to call S
Robinson
please hi I'm s Robertson um I farm with
my folks milk cows in hawkon New
Hampshire and uh we also raise about 150
to 200 acres of corn silage and then a
few hundred acres of grass also um
just uh speaking in support of the the
bill so we can do the Drone spraying um
as far as the bur cucumber is a huge
headache for us um just to give you an
idea you know when we've had issues with
it not getting sprayed in time and um on
certain Fields we've lost more than
2third of the Corn that we we basically
have to run it over with the trucks
because the the Harvester won't pick it
up it plugs the Harvester up so bad that
we just end up running it over and
leaving it in the field um and uh where
we to avoid that we have gotten Uh
custom operator in to spray with their
self-propelled sprayer like we've heard
a few times now um and that's that's
saved us saved the corn for the most
part but we still have you know the
Wheel tracks through the field obviously
are knocking down corn and damaging it
which is better than 2/3 lost but but
still an amount of damage that we could
avoid with drones um as far as you know
the height with it whether it's more
like spraying from the ground or more
like spraying from an airplane I think
that question was asked earlier where
with the custom operator their spray
boom is you know around 10 feet off the
ground already so it wouldn't be
significantly different if we were
flying a drone up to 20t you know and um
the other thing that I've heard again I
haven't like Tom was saying I haven't uh
done any drone spraying myself but what
talking with folks that do work with it
the that down pressure air from the
Drone propellers actually helps push the
spray down and keep it from drifting
away from the field from where you want
it directed um I don't know if you guys
for I don't know if you guys have seen
any Burg cucumber familiar with it but
the the corn fields over by the hospital
off exit to on Clinton Street those deal
those fields have had issues with bur
cucumber and you can see it it'll climb
right up it's got big wide leaves on it
and it'll grow right over the top of it
and knock it all down but um yeah so I I
think it would be a real uh
real important for
us uh financially it would help us
reduce our pesticide usage for the
reasons that have been spoken to um and
then the other thing thing is
that as New Hampshire has got fewer and
fewer dairy farms um there are it's
harder for I think it's harder for uh
applicators custom applicators to
justify buying a three half or 3/4 of a
million machine million dollar machine
where the drones are much more
affordable it they're easier to get um
transport on roads you know on a trailer
from field to field
um I think that would be a really big
Advantage too um for that would be
specifically ADV advantageous for New
Hampshire um I'll be happy to take any
questions oh thank you very much
representative viig just a clarification
when you're talking about uh the Drone
being more affordable than the half to
3/4 million machine is that machine
you're referring to the self-propelled
ground spray rig yeah yeah okay
thanks any other questions
thank you sir appreciate your testimony
seeing no further questions and I'd like
to call
creep good afternoon I'm Adam Creek uh
got a dairy farm up in bosin New
Hampshire um I grow about 400 acres of
corn silage um I'm in support of this
bill as I would believe it be
advantageous for us um as far as
reducing our fuel usage our chemical
usage um getting out on the fields when
a lot of times you can't with a tractor
you know if you get a big rain event
which seems like happens a lot lately uh
usually could go a week before you can
get out there with a tractor you know
with a drone you can get out there the
next day um it's uh you know be short
and sweet but I'm in support of this
belt oh that's perfect thank you sir
appreciate your testimony any
questions seeing no questions very
important testimony thank you so much
thank
you I am out of pink
cards uh any aliis that would like to
speak seeing none uh close the
[Music]
and online on 1698 we had 17 in favor 10
opposed on the blue sheet we have
favor
I
thank you everyone for coming out to
it thank
you
okay
all
right
okay I am going to open up the hearing
for HB 1703 relative to the sale of
kangaroo and Caribou meat and today uh
we have representative Granger to
introduce the bill to us good afternoon
agriculture uh thank you madam chair um
this bill is pretty simple it uh Le
utilizes kangaroo and Caribou farming
for meat production um we just uh
instead of rewriting a bunch of law we
just put kangaroo and Caribou in lists
of uh similar animals so they'll be
regulated basically the same way I can
take any questions okay first of all I
want to ask committee members do you all
have a copy of the bill took it off the
counter you took it off the counter okay
uh I don't think I have a copy
all right uh let's see anybody have any
questions regarding
um representative dsy okay thank you
madam chair um representative Granger uh
where did this bill come from was it a
constituent or um how um was this
addressed erased as a problem in New
Hampshire can you give us any background
yeah so uh one of my constituents uh
runs a nonprofit called the freest State
Food Network and they want to uh have
they come from a state where kangaroo
farming is legal um also there is
another constituent who uh wants to
raise Caribou as well and um the we
figured the best way to do it is just
regulate it the same way similar animals
are
regulated represent
Penza so I had no idea that this was a
thing and um and it was in a chat that
I'm in just recently and a whole group
of people were talking about
um reps and others about how they
purchase um kangaroo meat and um Caribou
meat so can you give a little background
please because you know this um you know
even to me it seemed um a little like
out there but about that process and
where PE how people are purchasing that
meat now can you give a little
background please uh certainly uh so
right now most meat so kangaroo is a
very common thing to eat in Australia
because that's where kangaroos are um I
would like to say that I know this from
firsthand experience but uh I've never
actually eaten kangaroo because it's
incredibly expensive um supposedly it's
kind of like beef mixed with rabbit it's
a somewhat gamier version of meat uh
beef supposedly it's a lot leaner than
beef and uh therefore healthier
depending on uh uh on your specific diet
uh other parts of the country do have
kangaroo as a a legal animal to raise
and butcher if you're coming if you're
importing uh if you're buying the most
commonly available kangaroo which is
from Australia um it is a a fairly Hefty
tax my understanding is $15 per pound
which is uh makes makes it outrageously
expensive for anybody to purchase
kangaroo meat um I don't know that there
is a large demand for kangaroo meat but
there certainly is some demand because I
demand it and uh so there's at least a
little bit and um so if if we did
legalize it then
not every farmer would be raising
kangaroo I'm pretty sure but there's
probably a few that will and uh that
would just enable that specific Market
to exist representative
com thank you madam chair and uh thank
you representative for taking my
question um could you elaborate on what
states currently allow the raising of
kangaroos my understanding is Wisconsin
Texas um well I'll tell you I do know
that that uh kangaroo meat is used for
um like cat and dog
food um I know that in California
though um because my daughter has a cat
that's allergic to most foods and her
vet recommended um that she get some
kangaroo meat for the cat um the only
problem is that that's banned in
California kangaroo meat
so um so that's how I know that uh you
know there it is a a product that is um
used in animal food so um I know that
not just people eat it representative
ktoa thank you madam chair um having
heard a discussion regarding kangaroos
just recently in this
committee
um uh but and about their personalities
and and things like that um what type of
infrastructure uh would you need to
raise kangaroos do you have any idea if
if if your infrastructure will my
understanding is and I'm not I'm not a
kangaroo farmer so you know just going
to give you the research that I've uh
found if you are capable of
containing you know some of the animals
that are already on the list such as bis
you should have absolutely no trouble um
with kangaroo they do hop um they are
capable of climbing but um they are
containable and they are capable of
being farmed um at at any rate it is up
to the farmer if you're uh worried about
them getting out and a nice thing about
kangaroos is they have basically zero
natural viability in this area um so if
they did Escape there's almost no chance
that they would become an invasive
species um there are other animals that
are much more compatible with our
natural environment such as Hogs and
while they are a small problem in New
Hampshire uh they're not that big of a
problem because we have very responsible
farmers who take care of um escaped pigs
uh there is very little chance that
kangaroos would be able to survive in
the wild in New
Hampshire represent Murray thank you
madam chair um and thank you for taking
my question I think that gets um to a
question that I was actually wondering
about is whether or not
um outdoor or indoor environments I
guess would have to be EST lished to
make sure that like housing or the
farming of these animals was compatible
with the ability to care for them it
seems that you uh I
guess the potential was that you
indicated that outdoor life for exact
kangaroo might not necessarily be
compatible so have you given any thought
to that so there are certain animals
that there's questions of how long it
takes before uh you can Slaughter the
animal um so for instance um it takes
about it takes a fairly long time for a
beefer to be something that you can
process uh kangaroos my understanding is
it's a lot shorter and uh therefore you
don't have to have them outside or in a
barn in the winter um they are capable
of handling cold to a certain degree um
but uh they ideally you would get it
done before that so you don't have to uh
have the kangaroo in the in the winter
time and you know ultimately they are
they are livestock they are not pets so
represent Bixby yeah so uh for um for
deer and Elk uh the fish and game rules
have specific enclosure requirements and
uh I don't see anything in the bill
about uh updating fish and game rules to
uh to make the uh the enclosure
requirements appropriate for kangaroos
um I did a little bit of online research
there's is a kangaroo Farm in British
Columbia that would which would suggest
it's probably viable in terms of climate
wise here uh but they did talk about an
issue being digging so there there would
be need to be different rules than what
we have now is that something that uh
you gave any thought to so I I looked
into the fishing game rules uh
specifically about uh permitting and uh
nothing in this bill as it is right now
addresses the permitting aspect of it um
I imagine if we have as livestock then
fishing game would need to go ahead and
update their rules in regards to in
regards to that I believe fishing game
does have the authority to update their
rules um to reflect updates in the
rsas um if if there if something needs
to be addressed specifically within this
bill um I I think an amendment uh would
be in order I tried to make sure that we
dotted our te's and crossed our eyes but
um I when it comes to actually
containing the animal um if you're
importing an animal from Australia um
you don't want it to you you you don't
want it to get out so it would be in the
farmer's interest to make sure just on
their own even without any rules to make
sure that the animal doesn't
escape uh I have a question and then you
so in your bill on page
two um line
32 um so a copy of s report show a
company that bike Elson Red Deer
kangaroo Caribou carcass to the
processing facility do you know if there
are any processing facilities that
process kangaroo um I do not uh I I uh
we just tried to put the the kangaroo
and the Caribou in existing rsas um if
uh does the I I'm not entirely sure
maybe that would be a a question for uh
the I forget his
name Mr Jasper okay but um I'm not 100%
on that no representative Bixby did you
have a question oh you had a question uh
representative Murray I'm sorry s you
got thank you um I had a a two-part
question my first was with regard to
marsupi like kangaroos I are there has
our state veterinarian waigh in on
zoonotic disease transfer or any
concerns around um those issues
for uh with regard to Kangaroo so we did
look into diseases that kangaroos carry
and if you'll notice
on at the second okay it's on
page it's on the third uh page uh line
eight uh we didn't include Caribou in uh
in sec in area in in K uh or we didn't
include kangaroo because they do not get
chronic wasting disease um there there
may be diseases that they get but I'm
not aware of them uh that may be I'm I'm
not aware of them and I couldn't find
them when I looked looked it
up represent Penza
okay she have a follow I did go ahead oh
I'm sorry go ahead follow up hey and I
was just going to say with regard to Ser
uh so there most of what is referred to
in this bill is Serv a species um prior
to your Amendment so the addition of a
marsupial into this um that was my other
question and it seems that you had kind
of answered parts of that
Penza so I guess my question is um in
regards with the bill it's it's
basically adding in these two um these
two animals to in this process and then
fishing game would uh put in rules or
whatever for all restrictions and
perating do you believe that we could
look at another state that's doing this
you said Wisconsin for example and um or
would you provide that information
possibly to the committee so they can
kind of see what is happening there
another state that is you know currently
doing this have as an operation it's
working for them would you be willing to
do that if if you want I can uh I can I
think OS can do a better job at that
than I can I I did as you know research
for this bill just sort to check in
Wisconsin specifically but OS they're
probably more efficient at because you
know every state has their own way of
keeping track of the rules and all that
I I could I could do that and I'll give
you a copy I'll write down to do that
okay
okay okay represent Bixby so um I'm I'm
glad that you included Caribou in terms
of the the testing for uh chronic
wasting disease uh but um I did a little
bit of research about uh Caribou in uh
well it was it was actually in Maine
they tried to reestablish Caribou in
Maine back in the
1980s uh importing animals from Newfound
land and one of the pro and the animals
they
reimported uh all died within about a
year of the time that they imported them
because there were diseases in the
native herds that were um basically the
the Caribou were not able to deal with
like like Rin worms and I'm wondering if
you see that as a potential in
impediment to this working here in New
Hampshire so I spoke to people who are
interested in raising caribou and in the
North Country I I believe that Santa's
Village has caribou and
they uh the problem they're experiencing
is they can't import new caribou and so
that leads to genetic issues um but the
reason that they have them and almost
nobody else does is because they were
grandfathered in before the current
rules were in place and so that means
that there's an issue for them and for
other people who want to raise
Caribou uh getting getting the genetic
stock into a a breeding population is is
difficult but that does prove that they
are uh viable in a farm environment in
New
Hampshire represent so so that actually
brings up another question which is
actually the sourcing because at this
point
um any the the rules have servid day all
Ser day that would be farmed are need to
be closed herds uh because uh the
chronic wasting disease is considered a
danger to uh for importing other animals
even if they've been certified they've
been uh so deer farms and Elk farms in
other states have ended up getting
chronic wasting disease because of
animals they've imported uh so do you
are you looking to um somehow change the
or relax the restrictions on
importing I'm mostly just trying to add
so it I I believe that you are current
able to import Red Deer and red
oh okay we we had a study committee on
okay well so the the current RSA not the
part that I Chang mentions Red Deer and
how how to handle them and make sure
that they don't have chronic wasting
disease so I if it's in the RSA I mean I
could be wrong about this but I assume
that if it's in the RSA and it says that
this is how handle a red deer um if
you're farming Red Deer then you would
be able to get a red deer right so the
fishing game rules actually have it
restricted to being a closed herd with
both Red Deer and Elk okay um so in in
in that case um I know that fishing game
has a separate list they have a they
have a they have a license of animals
you are allowed to or animals you must
have a license to possess and I believe
that the uh one complaint that people
have with that is that it's they don't
issue licenses for certain animals and I
believe they also have a list of f FIS
803 and FIS 804 of ones you need a
license to import and um is it so if you
don't mind me asking questions of the
committee um well I don't know go go for
it okay um
so is is is the difficulty in that the
fishing game won't issue the licenses
for for importing of Red Deer even
though it isn't technically illegal per
the
rsas represent big so uh fishing game is
authorized by the rsas to uh make
restrictions that are appropriate
for uh any disease issues that they
identify with any stock of animals so um
so they are they are authorized by the
rsas to say no you can't import Red Deer
no you can't import elk be and the basis
for that is that uh is the chronic
wasting disease and New Hampshire is
currently free of
CWD but uh other states not too far from
us have had uh CWD enter through farmed
animals like New York had an issue with
that uh and they want to make sure that
we don't get CWD into our native
population because it's a bad for people
and B it's very hard to get rid of and
it's also bad for hunters so I know uh
so one of the people that was pushing
for this bill has a about a 400 acre set
of land and they would like to be able
to have caribou and uh he has done a lot
more research into this uh than I have
and uh he wasn't able to be here today
um however I can get him to give written
testimony addressing that if you
like sure thank you any other questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative Granger and I just called
now Don um sorry Dan Burger on from New
game good afternoon I'm Dan berron I'm
the chief of the wildlife division at
New Hampshire Fish game um I might be
able to add some clarity to some of the
questions that were asked um so I'm I'm
here to testify on behalf of the
department in opposition of this bill um
largely due to the inclusion of caribou
um so Caribou currently under our
administrative rules are prohibited for
importation um and as has been discussed
here the main concern is chronic wasting
disease um how it works is as was
referenced the the statute gives the
department Authority um to set
regulations on importation propagation
possession of certain species um
currently all servid species so members
of the deer family are prohibited under
our rules for importation with the
exception of phow deer um phow deer is
one is is essentially one of the few
servid species that um after um you know
years of research there's no indication
that they're really susceptible to
chronic wasting disease um I believe
there was one scenario where um they
were able to they were able to infect
the phow deer after you know injecting
the pron into its brain um but even in
all those circumstances they didn't they
didn't necessarily um contract the
disease so that is the one species that
appears to not be susceptible to CWD and
is allowed for importation um the reason
that elk and red deer are included in
here is because prior to really prior to
CWD becoming a big uh a big concern
which which really took off in the early
2000s um there were already existing
herds in the state um so there's a
number of facilities throughout the
state that already propagate um Red Deer
um elk some have fallow deer um so we
wanted to allow those people who
currently had those animals to retain
possession of those animals what we
wanted to prevent was the importation of
new animals um because as has been
pointed out that is a very big risk of
introduction of chronic wasting disease
um chronic wasting disease is a preon
disease so it's an abnormal protein um
it is always fatal and there is no cure
um and it is very very expensive to
contain the disease once it once it
establishes itself um state wildlife
agencies end up spending millions of
dollars um they usually do drastic herd
reductions um this would impact if
chronic wasting disease were to get into
the state um this would impact our
native deer um as well as our MO
population which is already um as as
most people know facing some pretty
serious threats through um the mortality
based from Winter tick um so we have we
have concerns that um again nothing in
this bill would allow the importation um
but what it would do is create a market
for Caribou and we think a desire for
people to try and force us to remove
Caribou from that that restricted
species list for importation and I'm
happy to answer any questions
representative Bixby so do you have any
objection to
kangaroos um not not I we I don't know a
lot about kangaroos I don't not not as
pets but as as as as livestock um our
main concern is Caribou um it's a little
concerning to have it added into our RSA
to just say it's it's it would be
allowed without a permit we'd like to
retain because we within the within the
administrative rules that are associated
with this RSA we have um different
categories of species so there's
prohibited species controlled species
non-controlled species um we'd like to
be able to retain the authority to to
put that maybe on a non-controlled
species list in the event that a disease
were to pop up we could easily move it
to a you know prohibited species list
but our main concern is certainly with
Caribou because of chronic wasting
disease representative Murray thank you
madam chair um and thank you for taking
my question have you had a chance to
talk with the state veterinarian or even
health and human services around around
zoonotic diseases that Caribou uh might
carry and
pose uh concern or threat yeah there's
there's and Kangaroo sorry I don't know
if I said caribou and Kangaroo yeah Kang
kangaroos I'm not aware of any um I I
have um I I do speak fairly routinely
with the State Vet um I'm not aware of
any that kangaroos carry I'm not aware
of any zoonotic diseases that are of
great concern with Caribou either um the
main concern is chronic wasting disease
currently there's no solid evidence that
chronic wasting disease is transmissible
to people although there has been some
research with primates that suggests
that it's possible so cdc's current
recommendation is that um people do not
eat um known known infected um venison
or in venison from from um cids that are
known to be infected with chronic
wasting disease um but as far as
zoonotic diseases um you know I know
white tailed deer de um you know there
was some recent work that showed that
white ta deer were capable of of
Contracting Corona virus um whether or
not that's been documented in Caribou I
haven't seen um but again even with even
with covid and white tail deer there's
no indication that that's a risk to
humans right follow up thank you um one
of the things that I had recently read
was from the University of Texas where
there are some herds of kangaroo that
they are studying and that was around
toxoplasmosis and as a a woman who uh
anybody who's pregnant can have the um
exposure in cats to toxoplasmosis so a
similar concern has been raised uh
through the University of Texas about
toxoplasmosis in uh study environments
um so I I would want to be very careful
if we're looking at herds where there's
the potential
to if there's susceptibility between
cats and humans and uh the kangaroos
themselves so I I'd like to know a
little bit more and I don't know if you
could procure any more information on
that that would be helpful yeah and I I
can certainly coordinate with the State
Vet um he would probably be be better to
answer some of those questions but we we
could work together to look into some of
that in terms of what um what zoonotic
diseases maybe maybe um kangaroos are
susceptible to but again our our main
concern from a wildlife perspective and
the Department's perspective is chronic
wasting
disease okay any other questions
representative Penza I just had have a
quick question because definitely not
educated in chronic wasting disease so
um so if you're going to import an
animal is is there any way for you to
know because I understand I know the
duration right I know there's a from
exposure so is there any way to know
that that animal's clean before coming
because if there is what there is not no
so there's currently no approved live
animal tests for the disease so to to
test and feel even remotely confid
um the animal has to be has to be dead
the um so there's you know animals can
take up to 18 months to even exhibit
symptoms um the um as was referenced
before so USDA does have a herd
certification program um that that
certain herds um will will take part in
U particularly if they're going to move
interestate um the uh but you you know
that certifies a herd as low risk for
CWD but not no risk and there have been
multiple herds so typically a a herd has
to show that it has not tested any
animals positive for CWD over the course
of five years there's been numerous
cases of herds that after that 5year
period have still tested positive and
they you know their requirements that
they have to be getting animals from
other CWD certified herds to retain
their certification so um while while
the certification program certainly has
some benefits and reduces risk it it has
not done a good job at removing the risk
and there are still states that that end
up getting their first positives through
importing captive
servant follow
up so if um if you know let's say we
opened it up for let's just say for
Caribou for example and um it it it's a
it's closed and it you know that happens
even though it's you know we basically
put in criteria that could only be
through this certified USDA certified um
grouping and it wipes it out that's
really how is that going to impact
anything else except for the person that
is running this business so um so
typically a lot of times the so if if
the CWD were to come in on a captive
animal um again because there's this
there's this dormant period where you
may not know that the animal's positive
um so the animal the entire time it's in
it's it's infected can be shedding these
proteins or these um prons and they can
get spread out into the environment um
you know it could be through
contaminated farming equipment that that
leaves the farm or um you know fence
line contact with with native animals um
and the protein can actually remain
infective in the soil for um they don't
know exactly but there's similar
proteins um that impact sheep and it
causes a similar disease called Scrapy
um those have been remained active in
the soil for like 12 years um so the
protein itself is almost impossible to
deactivate um it can withstand
temperatures that you know are over a
thousand degrees um it it's it it's
resistant against chemicals um it's it's
a very scary disease and again the
problem is there's
been I can think of two jurisdictions
New York being one and Quebec being the
other um they documented the disease
soon enough and were able to put up a
containment Zone around those areas and
they have yet to detect more positives
um but Quebec spent you know millions of
dollars in the first couple of years to
contain that disease before it spread
into wild animals um again because this
protein could remain active in the soil
there's nothing saying that 5 years from
now they might find it in Wild deer but
um to date they have not um New York
similar millions of dollars in
containment um to stop the spread of
this disease into into wild
animals sure do we have any information
that's um specific on New Hampshire and
if we do just because I'm interested and
I think other members of the committee
would be about you know anything um that
happened in New Hampshire in regards
with chronic waste yes so we do um so
the department does annual surveillance
for chronic wasting disease we typically
get around 400 samples from um um Hunter
harvested white tail deer we pull lymph
nodes from those animals and we send
them to a lab for testing um that gives
us some confidence um that if we were to
have it we may find it um we also test
any suspect animals so if there's any
animals that are displaying you know
your typical symptoms of chronic wasting
disease we'll euthanize those pull
samples have those tested um to date
we've been doing that testing since
about 2002 we've yet to find a positive
um however there are uh I I won't
remember the state off hand um I want to
say it was Iowa or Idaho um about four
or five years ago when they first
detected chronic wasting disease I don't
believe they did annual surveillance um
they detected the disease they ramped up
their surveillance and it was very
evident that that disease had been in
that state for quite some time because
they were finding it very far from where
the first cases showed up um so again it
was kind of lingering in the state
quietly for a number of years before
before they finally found a positive and
then when they increased their
surveillance they found out they had it
far more widespread than they had
initially
thought representative Murray you madam
faon isn't it true that chronic Wasing
disease is
neurodegenerative it is
yeah okay any other
questions thank you Mr burun thank you
really appreciate your
testimony Joan O'Brien Nation uh New
League good
afternoon good afternoon so um on behalf
of the nental rights
League I would um respectfully request
that the committee oppose House Bill
1703 to allow the raising butchering and
sale of kangaroo Caribou meet in New
Hampshire big
surprise um our concerns center around
Animal Welfare but I also want to
comment on something that didn't come up
when the sponsor introduced the bill but
that came up in the Press around the
bill I think some people from the Free
State Food Network were interviewed and
I read some things and what they were
saying was that this would be a more
sustainable way to farm animals and that
that's why they were bringing forth this
idea of
kangaroos who basically produce no
methane as compared to a cow and I guess
Caribou are more sustainable because
they eat very little so I was expecting
some discussion around that since I had
read that in the paper and I am going to
comment on that but first the welfare
concerns um the challenges of kangaroo
farming aside um not having been
domesticated
yet Kangaroos and to a lesser extent
Caribou have the potential to suffer
from the confines and husbandry
practices of farm life even more than
domesticated farmed animals do for the
following reasons kangaroos are
accustomed to traveling many miles a day
and are known to die of stress when
confined
uh climate wise Caribou could
conceivably do better in New Hampshire
than kangaroos however given that these
animals are known for having the longest
land migration on the planet they walk
2,000 miles a year um between their
winter and summer grounds confining them
would be unnatural at
best so regarding the uh Freestate food
networks press around this being a more
sustainable way to raise animals for
food
I really appreciate that that came up in
the Press because it shows that people
recognize that animal agriculture is a
major source of carbon emissions and
climate
change which is a topic that was
addressed in a recent talk by Dr Allison
leech of the UNH sustainability
Institute and I've got some some
information about that on the back but
this bill only allows for Kangaroo
farming on a small scale
in the same way that deer bison and so
are farmed in New Hampshire to serve a
niche market it's unrealistic to expect
that allowing kangaroo and Caribou
farming in New Hampshire would have a
significant impact on
climate swapping cows for kangaroos on a
scale large enough to mitigate climate
change would require a complete remodel
of the current beef industry from which
crops we grow to feed our animals all
the way to the design of slaughter
houses rather than adding two new
animals to the menu the the Free State
Food Network and others wishing to
reduce carbon emissions could simply eat
less meat or none at all thank
you okay any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you so much
for your
testimony and I now call um commissioner
Agriculture
thank you Madame chairman members of the
committee and I am borrowing your
statutes here I didn't have enough time
to to do my homework on this um so I am
concerned um and you know I would
suggest to you I I asked to go last
because I was waiting to hear from the
kangaroo and bison or Caribou Farmers um
and I'm always concerned when we just
add things in and there's actually
nobody who is is here we did hear about
somebody who would like to do caribou
but we don't have any in the state and
they're not going to be allowed to be
imported um and I don't think I heard
anything about kangaroo Farmers so why
would we be adding these things in and
and but where my my
statutory concern is that if you go to
page two of the
bill um line eight it talks about
Slaughter on a farm so if you actually
234a the word in Roman one it talks
about livestock you have and it so what
does it mean to have livestock well you
go
to back and forth here but
4272 this goes way
back I don't know where it starts but
the definition of livestock under uh 18
section 18 of 472a shall include and
limits all the things but when we get to
like Buffalo it says domestic
domesticated strains of Buffalo etc etc
etc now we go to the bill and it is not
including these animals in livestock but
it's saying raised on a farm but Farm
doesn't include these things so the bill
has
statutory um problems in that you're now
saying it's a farm but it's not part of
farming it's not part of livestock what
are these animals and how are they they
controlled if you want to do this I
think you need to to fix uh that problem
as
well um and
also the bill itself refers back to um
RSA 143 A5 exemptions Roman 9 a farm
owned or operated by any person firm or
corporation that raises bison elk or Red
Deer for human consumption it refers to
that section but does not now include
kangaroos or Caribou in there so that's
very confusing so you would need to
adjust that section as as well um so
those are my concerns as as commissioner
that we're by simply adopting this bill
as it you would be creating a a
nightmare and I'm not sure exactly how
we deal with this but I would certainly
be opposed to adding these
undomesticated animals into the
definition of livestock to solve one
part of the problem GL to take any
questions okay so basically what you're
saying is that there would be
conflicts if this was adopted as written
there would be conflicts within
different parts of the rsas yes and and
I think you know for me as the
commissioner you know the most
problematic part is is saying that these
are um you can Farm them but you're not
including them in the definition of a
farm or livestock so you how are they
how are they dealt with it all and
um it just I see it as a as a huge
problem okay uh representative Bixby so
if assuming we were able to um sort out
the statutory issues would you have any
principled opposition to farming
kangaroos in this
state
um I I think as with anything you'd have
to find I would unless you have a
domesticated strain of of kangaroos
because to put a wild animal into the
definition of of livestock or farming is
a
committee um did did you have any other
um any other comment with regard to what
was reported or testified To Us by
fishing game regarding car no I I I
think you know there there is certainly
that issue of of the Caribou I don't
think that you can you can or perhaps
should even try to solve that by saying
oh we're not going to worry about
chronic wasting
disease um we'll just let them come in
and uh I I think that's a problem so uh
I I support their their testimony into
that in that area um and I think that
since we don't have Caribou here why
would we want to bring them in I'm told
they don't even have any Caribou in
Caribou main anymore so um really so I
don't know where these would come from
and again um I'm not I think we're we're
reacting to with this Bild there's a
reaction to something that is more gee
wouldn't it be nice if rather than we
have testimony from people who have come
in and say well here's a
domesticated uh strain of caribou and
I've had experience in raising Caribou I
here's a domesticated strain of
kangaroos I've had experience in doing
that I'm uh very concerned about just
saying oh well we'll we'll put something
in and they will come then who's going
to deal with with the Fallout from doing
something that is not thought about in
terms of how do we regulate this what's
the what are the leave the Caribou out
and just think about kangaroo you know
what are we don't have any native
kangaroos so how are we going to um deal
with them we they're not defined as
livestock I wouldn't want them design
defined as livestock uh what are we
doing to make sure that we're not
bringing diseased animals into the state
how are they going to be cared for
certainly the state veterinarians don't
have any experience in that right now
you know we get called in on uh to
assist the police with animal abuse
cases how would my my people do a body
score on kangaroos you know I don't
believe that they've had any training on
the care and body conditions of
kangaroos what are they supposed to look
look like if they're healthy what do
they look like if they're not how do we
do this I mean there is a whole lot of
things here that aren't thought about in
this bill it's just like okay let's just
do this
um just just throwing a bomb into the
middle of things we actually haven't had
any testimony submitted from the state
veterinarian and I wonder if um if you
may reach out to him and ask uh for him
to submit some sort of opinion or
thoughts regarding um regarding this
bill I mean aside from the Caribou piece
which we already understand that there's
a
very possible issue of chronic wasting
disease but I'd be interested to know if
there if he has any uh if he would like
to weigh in at all with any kind of a
zootic issue having to do with
kangaroo I I can certainly ask him he's
very very busy and so if this is
something that this committee is
seriously considering passing then I
could task him with that I would rather
not if um if my concerns have haven't
been enough to say we need to look at
this more if you're saying well
commissioner if you know if we don't get
testimony from the State Veterinary and
we're probably going to pass it okay
I'll do it but I really no no that's not
my int no I understand I'm just saying
he is so backed up with so many things
it's an area I know he has no expertise
in I can assure you that the state
veterinarian has never dealt with a
kangaroo and so asking them for for this
to to spend time I mean I I appreciate
what you're looking for but I really
hate to task him with this if I don't
have
to represent Penza I wouldn't have had a
question but because you kept having
some excellent testimony now I have a
question so okay so let's say that um
you know a group from let's say it be
Texas or Wisconsin and they have been
producing this they want to come to the
live for your die State whether it be
Caribou or whether it be kangaroo would
the department um and do you think would
fishing game be willing if there's
someone that has you know background
expertise have done this in another
state that is in operation would we be
willing to look at it well I'm I'm going
to tell you I would put that on fish a
game I know the answer to Caribou
because of the testimony we've heard
here I again would be opposed to putting
kangaroo in at
livestock um so that would go back to
fishing game how would they like to
handle it I would just tell you this
isn't you know by by talking about Farm
rais
kangaroos um you really need to amend
the definition of farming and of
livestock which I would oppose because I
believe these are wild animals not aware
of domestic strains I mean I suppose if
somebody oh yeah here's how you
domesticate it I we're off to this you
know this area that I don't even know
why we're going there because you don't
have anybody here coming saying Hey I
want to start farming Kangaroos and
we're taking up this this time and you
know I appreciate that's what the
legislature does but please unless
you're serious about hey we think
kangaroo farming is the greatest thing
since sliced bread I mean please yeah
I'm really more on the Caribou side than
kangaroo side but and that that's simply
you know I can tell you that Santa's
Village they are getting in a in a
situation where their genetics is is
very questionable and they have some
great protocols um they're not going to
be allowed to bring um more of those
reindeer in and so certainly and they're
already here so certainly for fishing
game to say oh yeah let's bring
something in we don't have so is Santa's
Village gonna eventually not have
reindeer oh no okay I'm not I I I I
can't I can't speak for them I'm telling
you it's a concern and I've been
involved in in discussions on that and
and right now they are not being allowed
to import anymore so representative
Bixby all right so um just a quick note
before I launch into my skeptical end of
things which is that when I was visiting
Australia I did have kangaroo it was
very tasty it was much like venison
uh however um what I one of the things
that I thought of immediately when this
bill came across our um list was uh the
study committee that we did last fall on
the lack of Slaughter facilities and
processing facilities for meat and I'm
just wondering what sort of impact this
would have on the uh existing problems
in Slaughter and processing this is a is
listed as a non amable species so it
doesn't have to go through the normal
inspection it's got to be the postmortem
under the the statute inspected post
morning by a veterinarian um again I'm
not sure because I'm not a veterinarian
never wanted to be a veterinarian um
what they would be looking for what they
would be trained to look for in kangaroo
meat I don't I don't know if that's easy
if it's not um so again we don't have a
veterinarian here to say oh yeah this is
is easy for me to do this because this
is about on Farm Slaughter of kangaroos
without uh going through the USDA
process representative Howard thank you
madam chair um I just have one quick
question and that is are you surprised
to find yourself talking about kangaroos
again in this
session well I knew it was on the list
so I'm not surprised but I was surprised
there were two bills dealing with
kangaroos
yes any other questions for the
commissioner seeing none thank you very
much we appreciate it thank you uh
anyone else wish to speak on this bill
know and and I would need a pink card
too
eventually good afternoon members of the
committee thank thank you madam chair
for allowing me to speak on HB 1703 for
the record my name is Colleen Smith I'm
the administrator for the food
protection section within the Department
of Health and Human Services while the
department is isn't taking a position on
this bill uh for reasons um that have
been covered we haven't had anyone come
to us expressing that they want to offer
either of these meets for sale uh we
also when it comes to the zoonotic
diseases that have been has been
questioned in previous testimony I can
tell you that from from tmop plasmosis
standpoint Australia has had outbreaks
of that associated with kangaroo meat
there have been pet food recalls
associated with salmonella and kangaroo
meat but we don't have a lot of
familiarity with with kangaroo meat in
this
country and happy to take any questions
that the committee may
have do you know if anybody import s
already processed kangaroo meat and
sells it in their stores in New
Hampshire so yes that is that would be
allowable import that's allowable
kangaroo
yes
okay all right any questions seeing none
thank you thank you for bringing that
out too appreciate
it all right uh anyone else wish to
speak and I guess not so with that um
sheet and
also
um I
saw
online let's see where did I put that
this so we have one person against on
the blue
sheet and let me just see
here
have online
1703 is
have two people support the bill and two
people oppose the Bill thank you with
that I'm going to close out the hearing
now we had
time put aside I guess this afternoon no
did we no no we did not hang
here all right
so
we oh yeah we had at 2:30 scheduled a
work session for hb1 1575 HP 1698 and HP
1703 um HP 1575 we have already um exact
so I don't know if you want to take any
time right now to talk about HB
1698 or HP
1703 we could um
add that next week at 10 o'clock we're
going to have a work session on the
paint recycle Bill and also the Drone
bill because I'm planning on working on
an amendment to bring to the committee
to fix that 55 pound limit for drones
and I I think I have a solution for that
um referring to a different section of
um uh of New Hampshire law actually um
there is a a a section below the section
that I that's mentioned um instead
of let's
see where is
it
yes instead of where I mentioned uh
using unmanned aircraft as designed
defined in RSA 422 colon 3
three Roman numeral 27-a I think it's
Roman numeral 30 that we can use that
refers to unmanned
aircraft not small unmanned aircraft so
I think that will fix that issue and um
well I'll I'll prepare the amendment um
but I'm going to talk to um Farm Bureau
and some other folks and see if we can
get that straightened out sub to OS and
bring that back to us representative com
thank you madam chair I think it's
imperative that um we get that the
amendment and I think it's uh and we
pass that next week uh it will be an
absolute useful tool for Farmers uh
going forward
absolutely so um so in so far as like a
work session now I mean I'm just telling
you what I'm going to do with that bill
and make an amendment representative
Bixby so I think uh clearly the the
Drone bill is something that we'll want
to discuss a little bit further on on
next Tuesday and I'm glad that you have
a fix that you have in mind for that
because I think it's an important bill
um and as for other the other bill um
I'm not sure that we could consider the
kangaroo an important bill uh and I'm
not sure that we need to spend much time
discussing that next Tuesday morning I
don't know is there I maybe we could
take a poll right now as see if there's
anyone who feels that we need to move
forward with that either as an OTP
is no I would yeah I would itl it number
one first of all even if the bill was
amended to remove Caribou I think the
issues that the commissioner has brought
out with difference of um issues within
the statutes do we want to
consider uh kangaroo as far Farm uh as a
farm animal and and go into that whole
thing but mostly I mean we don't see a
bunch of people testifying here that say
they want to start a kangaroo farm and
so I think that it's an issue that you
know we really is not something that's
uh you know shaking that that's Earth
shaking here I would agree okay anybody
else okay um I think then our work for
this after afternoon is done I want to
congratulate everybody for getting
through all the hearings for our house
bills we are done with those today and
the next set of hearings we would have
is uh any kind of Senate bills that come
to the committee they're not setting us
are they I don't
know I don't know maybe a couple here
and there maybe um but I want to thank
everybody for for all their work this uh
this past month two months uh three
months whatever uh We've we've gotten
through a lot of stuff I covered a lot
of ground and um I'm pleased to know
that
um we've we've passed so many things out
of this committee on consent and it just
makes me feel really really proud of all
of us that we can come together on on so
many different issues and let the other
stuff be what it is you know so thank
you everybody and I hope you have a
wonderful rest of the day and a pleasant
drive
home
e